ratkoll
...
Powertoys
AI
Ich weiß nicht was es ist, aber vielleicht AI
Cellphones, AI
AI
Und China-Chinesen-Kramer, wahrscheinlich auch AI
Also, die Trends diese Woche, wie gehabt, 95% AI
Gucken wir mal, ob in .net irgendwas spannendes trendet
Ja, das habe ich gelesen, es gab einen Bug in KeePass
Man kann Passwörter aus KeePass dumpen
Aber dazu brauchen die Leute eh schon mal Zugriff auf den Rechner
.net trendet, ok
Der Bulk-Crap-Uninstaller, ok, da scheint irgendein Windows-Ding zu sein
Unity-Kram
Entity-Framework
Windows-Optimizer, ne, das brauche ich nicht
China-Chinesen-Zeug, irgendwas mit Kubernetes, was auch immer das sein soll
Billy-Billy-Tool, keine Ahnung, was ist das Billy-Billy-Tool, ok
Irgendwas Kubernetes-mäßiges, was ist das?
Ah, Crypto-Weep-Stells
Billy-Billy
Ok, ich habe legit keine Ahnung, was es genau ist, aber alles klar
Jetzt muss ich noch Bescheid
Ah ja, und sonst?
Ich habe mal eine Frage an euch
Hat jemand von euch die Abschlussprüfung geschrieben?
Das wollte ich gestern eigentlich schon fragen, aber habe es dann irgendwie im Stream verdrängt wieder
Außer am Anfang
Es haben doch bestimmt einige von euch die Abschlussprüfung geschrieben
Gibt es da mittlerweile schon Ergebnisse?
Also gibt es da mittlerweile schon die Resultate, ob man durchgefallen ist oder nicht?
Guck mal noch einmal, Physi2003, Abschlussprüfung
Ergebnisse
Ne, ne, ne, nicht Ergebnisse, ähm, äh, äh, äh
Resultate, sowas
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was ich da suchen soll, sind die schon da?
Ah ja, anscheinend sind die da, guck mal
Er hat vorläufige Ergebnisse erhalten
Planung eines Softwareprojekts mangelhaft
Entwicklung und Umsetzung von Algorithmen ungenügend
Oh, der hat aber richtig reingeschissen, der Nick hier
Wirtschaft, der Wieso Teil 3, ok
69, 70, 90
Ich kann euch gar nicht, ich glaube ich hatte auch irgendwas um 70 Punkte oder so irgendwie
Ich hatte keine allzu gute Abschlussprüfung, dafür hatte ich eine gute Präsentation dann
Also anscheinend sind die Ergebnisse zumindest bei einigen vorläufig schon da
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht, also wenn ihr geschrieben habt, würde mich wirklich mal interessieren
Ok, also der hat schon, der hat schon die Ergebnisse, euer Azubi, ja
Verstehe ich das, verstehe ich das richtig
Hast du schon Ergebnisse?
Vorläufige? Mein Endgültig gibt es ja nicht, hast du schon vorläufige Ergebnisse?
Ok, ja weil es würde mich mal interessieren, wie es denn dieses Jahr ausgefallen ist
Wahrscheinlich, achso vor ein paar Jahren, achso
Ähm, weil dieses Jahr war ja das Geschreie besonders groß
Dass die, dass die noch beschissener ist als sonst die Abschlussprüfung
Was ich auch glaube, ich glaube die wird, das ist einfach, jedes Jahr ist die neue beschissenste Prüfung
Die untertreffen sich quasi jedes Jahr bei der IHK
Aber es wird wahrscheinlich am Ende so sein, dass ungefähr der gleiche Anteil besteht und durchfällt
Sag Reddit, was war die beste Entscheidung, die du je in deinem Leben getroffen hast?
Boah, also das kann ich, das kann ich, das kann ich so oft nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht sagen
Also, was auf jeden Fall eine gute Entscheidung war, den YouTube-Channel damals aufzumachen
Und, ähm, auch Teilzeit zu arbeiten war auch eine gute Entscheidung
Das Haus vom Opa nicht zu verkaufen, sondern einzuziehen war auch eine gute Entscheidung
Äh, nichts mit Holz zu machen und was mit Computer zu lernen war auch eine gute Entscheidung
Ja, Chat, ich, ich, ich, ich geb mal die Frage
Ich geb mal die Frage an euch weiter
Was war die beste Entscheidung in eurem Leben bisher?
Also das sind so vier Sachen, die mir schon mal so spontan einfallen
Andere Sachen müsste ich wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich länger drüber nachdenken, keine Ahnung
Weiß nicht
Ähm
Ich denke, auf jeden Fall eine gute Entscheidung war es jetzt auch, den Arbeitgeber zu wechseln
Wobei ich das jetzt nach, sagen wir mal, zwei Monaten natürlich noch nicht ranken kann
Als war das eine meiner besten Entscheidungen ever, weiß ich nicht
Aber es war auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee, weil ich gestern erst wieder mit einem Ex-Kollege vom alten Arbeitgeber geschrieben hab
Wie krass es da in den Bach runter geht
Okay, also was, also war es bei dir auch so, ja
Die, was wollten sie dir dann erzählen?
Also mir hat damals das Arbeitsamt erzählt, ich soll doch Schreiner oder sowas werden
Ich soll irgendwie mit Holz, Holzarbeit und mit Holz was machen
Und ich hab halt gesagt, nee, ich will was, ich will was mit Computer machen
Und da hat sich der, da hat sich der Depp vom Arbeitsamt damals noch drüber lustig gemacht
So, ja, ja, immer das Computerzeug
Und das war jetzt nicht, dass ihr denkt, das war irgendwie, irgendwie in, in, in ganz dunklen Zeiten oder so
Das war 1900, das, das, bei, mal überlegen
Ich bin 1984 geboren, wann, wann macht man das denn so?
Wahrscheinlich macht man das in so 8., 9. Klasse oder sowas
Mit wie vielen Jahren ist man in der 9. Klasse?
Okay, ich sag jetzt einfach mal, das wird wahrscheinlich so 1997, 1998 rum oder so gewesen sein, keine Ahnung
Und
Das heißt, damals war schon abzusehen, dass so Computer und Internet und Zeug vielleicht mal durchaus Zukunft hat
Aber nicht so der Typ im Arbeitsamt
Der Typ im Arbeitsamt, bei mir hat das auch nicht geschnallt
Der hat auch gemeint, ja, mach, mach doch was mit Holz
Ich, ich, ich hätte mich so sehr, was hat er gesagt, so sehr versteift, auf dass ich was mit Computer machen will
Ah ja
Und, wo ist das Problem?
Die sollen doch froh sein, dass mal jemand mit, mit 14, 15, 16, was auch immer weiß, was er machen will
Aber, mir ist es ja dann auch im Nachhinein erst eingeleuchtet
Aus seiner Sicht gibt das schon Sinn, weil
Man darf nicht davon ausgehen, dass die Typen beim Arbeitsamt in irgendeiner Art und Weise
Also auch wenn sich das Berufsberatung nennt
Dass die in irgendeiner Art und Weise jetzt Absichten hätten, dich zu beraten, was dir gefällt
Oder sowas in der Richtung, oder was, was für dich ist
Nee, nee
Das Einzige, was die im Sinn haben ist, ihre Statistik möglichst gut dastehen zu lassen
Und wenn es dort viele Unternehmen gibt, die sagen, sie finden keinen Nachwuchs
Keine Ahnung, wenn es da besonders viele Schreiner gibt, sagen wir mal
Die sagen, sie finden keine Nachwuchskräfte
Dann versuchen die Leute dazu zu bringen, eben was mit Holz zu arbeiten
Nicht wirklich, weil es für die Leute gut ist, sondern weil es für ihre Statistik gut aussieht
Das ist auch das Einzige
Also Arbeitsamt ist der allerletzte Drecksladen, da kann man sich auf nichts
Also du kannst dich weder so zur Beratung drauf verlassen, noch wenn du irgendwie arbeitslos bist
Das ist der Größte
Also das Beste, was man machen kann, ist nie in irgendeiner Art und Weise abhängig vom Arbeitsamt zu sein
Ja
Ich würde fast behaupten, dass das komplett normal ist
Dass man mit 14, 15, 16 da noch wenig Ahnung hat von dem, was man später machen will
Und auch danach, also es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als ist das für immer in Stein gemeißelt
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit kann man auch mit 30 plus noch eine zweite Ausbildung machen
Oder noch, wenn man wirklich noch Bock hat drauf, studieren, irgendwas anderes lernen
Und auch in dem Job, den man gerade macht, gibt es ja viele, egal was es ist
In irgendeiner Art und Weise immer noch Weiterentwicklungsmöglichkeiten
Wenn es auch nicht, es muss ja auch nicht zwangsläufig exakt in dem Job sein
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch andere, wo es aber gut ist, weil man die Vorkenntnisse hat aus dem aktuellen
Also in der heutigen Zeit ist es nicht mehr so, dass das, was du gelernt hast, du jetzt die nächsten 60 Jahre
Naja gut, 60 ist übertrieben, die nächsten 55 Jahre machen musst
Du wusstest sofort, dass du BWL und Management machen willst
Oh je
Ich weiß zwar nicht
Ich weiß zwar nicht, ob man freiwillig BWL und Management machen kann, aber wenn es was für dich ist, ist ja gut
Ne, aber das ist doch nice, wenn es manche Leute wissen, aber die meisten wissen es nicht
Also ich habe meine Ausbildung ja auch jetzt relativ spät gemacht
Ich überlege gerade, also wie alt war ich denn, als ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe
Ich glaube auch 24 oder so
Und das war für einige auch schon damals so, oh du bist aber schon ganz schön alt
24 ist nun wirklich jetzt kein Ding
Oder wie alt war ich denn 2007, ah 1984 minus 2007
Quick maths im Kopf, im Kopf null, ja 24 dann
In meinem Lehrjahr waren 28 Leute an der Berufsstunde, ich war nur einer
Unter 18 hatten wir glaube ich auch wenige auf jeden Fall, also wir hatten welche
So ein Kiffer, das weiß ich noch, der war den ganzen Tag bekifft, ich glaube der war nur 16 oder so
Der war geil, der hat nichts mitgekriegt, wenn du ihn gefragt hast immer
Der war echt den ganzen Tag komplett abwesend
Also wir hatten auch ein paar unter 18, aber sehr wenige im gesamten Klassendurchschnitt
Und ich war glaube ich auch mit 23, 24 noch gar nicht der Älteste dort
Ich meine ich habe zu den Älteren gehört, aber ich war auf jeden Fall nicht der Älteste dort
Wir hatten auf jeden Fall einen, von dem ich weiß, der war auf jeden Fall noch eine ganze Ecke älter
Richtig, sehe ich übrigens genauso
Ich bash ja mal ganz gerne irgendwelche BWL Konsulten, Dummschwätzer Leute
Aber gebe ich dir recht, also das Manager, die wissen wie man was managt
Oder die sagen wir mal so auch Projektleiter, die wissen, dass es nicht so sehr darum geht
Dass sie sich jetzt, also dass ein Projektleiten keine Selbstdarstellershow ist
Um zu zeigen, dass der Projektleiter der geilste auf der Welt ist
Sondern dass es darum geht, dem Projektteam oder den Projektmitarbeitern zu ermöglichen
Das Projekt gut umzusetzen, unter anderem als Projektleiter
Das ist tatsächlich mangelbar
Und gute Manager, also nicht nur gute Manager, man kann sagen gute Manager, gute Projektleiter
Auch gute Führungskräfte und sowas, da gibt es nicht viel, aber die sind wichtig
Die sind genauso wichtig wie alles andere auch
Auch wenn man immer mal ganz gerne dagegen flamed, aber es gibt halt auch leider wenig Gescheite
Also ich würde mal sagen, bei den meisten würde es ohne fast besser gehen
Aber wenn man mal einen guten Teamleiter hatte oder einen guten Projektleiter, dann merkst du den Unterschied schon
Das läuft einfach deutlich besser und man muss sich um viele Sachen auch als Techniker gar nicht mehr kümmern
Wenn man zum Beispiel einen guten Teamleiter hat, dann kann man ansprechen, hier das und das macht Probleme
Und dann sagt der, ah ja gut, ich bespreche das mal hier auf unserem nächsten was auch immer
Und dann macht er das auch und dann klärt sich das
Leider gibt es da halt recht wenige von
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dass die meisten Ausbildungen schon immer Schrott waren
Meine Ausbildung war auch Schrott
Das einzig Gute in meiner Ausbildung war, dass ich vieles lernen konnte, weil ich wollte, weil es mich interessiert hat
Also wirkliche Ausbildung mit Plan gab es bei uns ja nicht
Es gab so, ey guck mal, hat jemand Bock das zu machen oder will sich das jemand mal angucken
Und da hattest du halt die Chance, relativ viel mitzubekommen und zu lernen und zu sehen in der Zeit, wenn es dich halt interessiert hat
Also die Grundlage dessen, dass ich heute immer noch Geld mit Linux verdiene, war eindeutig damals auch meine Ausbildung beim Provider
Ich habe da so viel gelernt, was Linux und Serverbetrieb und sowas angeht, das hätte ich wahrscheinlich in vielen anderen Ausbildungen nicht gelernt
Und ich habe es da halt nicht in der Ausbildung gelernt, weil man gesagt hätte, das war jetzt quasi geplanter Teil der Ausbildung
Das war eher so, ey hier guckt mal, da ist irgendwas kaputt, guckt mal, dass das irgendwie wieder geht
Das war die Ausbildung, guckt mal, dass das irgendwie wieder geht
Und entweder hätte ich mich drei Jahre da hingesetzt und Däumchen gedreht, hätte auch keinen interessiert
Oder ich habe drei Jahre was gelernt und ich habe halt tatsächlich drei Jahre sehr viel in Linux gelernt, hauptsächlich, weil es mich interessiert hat
Ich bin ja danach auch nicht lange im Ausbildungsbetrieb geblieben, ich glaube ein Jahr oder sowas
War ich dann noch beim Provider und dann haben die auch angefangen ganz komische Dinge zu machen
Ja, da gebe ich dir recht
Was ich auch immer cringe finde bei irgendwelchen Führungskräften ist, die dir schon beim ersten Treffen erzählen, mein Vorbild ist Elon Musk oder sowas
Wo ich mir dann immer denke, ja und, wir sind ja aber weder Tesla oder wenn sie dann irgendwas von Google, wir sind weder Tesla, Google, Microsoft noch sonst was
Wo ich mir dann denke, was, was, was wollt ihr mir damit sagen
Ja, also, da weiß ich gleich schon, mit denen komme ich nicht gut aus
Und es bestätigt sich ja auch meistens dann
So YouTube, was empfiehlt ihr uns denn heute?
Was verdient ein Flugbegleiter?
Nuki Ring, ach du Kacke, bloß nicht
Also weder Nuki noch Ring, also Nuki geht ja noch irgendwie, wenn man da Bock drauf hat
Und smarte Türschlösser haben will, wobei hatte Nuki nicht auch mal diesen komischen Bug, dass man Leute inviten konnte zu sich in die, in die, ins Haus
Also dass man quasi Freunde adden konnte, die aufschließen konnten und dieser Freundesinvite-Link war public für alle
Ich bilde mir ein, da war doch was mit Nuki
Also, um das jetzt nochmal in klare Worte zu fassen, für alle, die nicht verstanden haben, was ich, was ich erzählt hab
Also, Nuki stellt, ich bin mir aber wohlgemerkt, bevor mich Nuki jetzt verklagt
Ich muss gleich sagen, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das Nuki war oder nicht irgendein anderer Smart-Log-Hersteller
Aber ich bilde mir ein, es gab mal bei einem Smart-Log-Hersteller und ich, ich bilde mir ein, das war Nuki, aber das muss nicht so gewesen sein
Gab es mal einen, gab es mal einen Bug, da konnte man von der, von der Smartphone-App für dieses, für dieses Schloss, dieses smarte Türschloss
Konnte man Leute inviten, um ihnen Zugriff zum eigenen Haus, zur eigenen Wohnung oder zu diesem Raum, mit dem, was halt mit dem Schloss gesichert war, zu ermöglichen
Aber dieser Invite-Mechanismus war kaputt, sodass das public zugänglich war
Also sprich, es konnten sich Leute public über diesen Invite-Mechanismus einladen zu eurem Haus und dann mit ihrem Handy die Tür aufschließen
Ist aber schon Jahre her und selbst wenn die das gewesen sind, ich vermute mal, dass sie das mittlerweile im Griff haben
Aber ist schon, ist schon ziemlich für den Arsch sowas
Das ist auch so, ich glaube auch die Anfänge aus dieser ganz Smart-Home, ähm, Smart-Log-Geschichte mit zig Sicherheitslücken und solchen Problemen
Ich, ich glaube das, daran liegt das auch, dass ich mich nie ernsthaft mit Smart-Logs beschäftigt hab und auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf habe, irgendwelche Türen mit smarten Türschlössern
Also zumindest Türen, worauf, wo es drauf ankommt, mit irgendwelchen smarten Türschlössern auszustatten
Ja
Und Ring, gut, ich mein Kameras, die du abonnieren musst, um Basic-Funktionen zu, wo du ein Abo abschließen musst
Oder die Kamera kaufen musst und ein Abo abschließen musst, für Basic-Funktionen, das kommt mir eh nicht ins Haus
Oh, please allow me to interject for a moment
Fünf Gründe Software-Entwickler zu werden
Also Videos haben wir uns in letzter Zeit schon zu viele angeguckt
Dev-Home
Äh, was ist das?
Also es ist ja gerade Build, glaube ich, ja
Ich muss ja auch noch ein paar Webcasts mir angucken, gab ein paar interessante Themen
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir uns auch den ein oder anderen mal zusammen angucken
Nicht jetzt, vielleicht in einem, vielleicht in einem anderen Stream
Was Microsoft, was Microsoft da so vorstellt
Äh, ich bin aber skeptisch, ob was Interessantes dabei ist
Okay, was ist, was ist Dev-Home?
Das muss ich mir gleich mal angucken, irgendwie, was?
Your new productivity companion on Windows 11
Oh, nee, please, come on
Help you quickly set up your Easy-Connect Git
Hä?
Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas, wo ich keinen Bock drauf habe, es zu benutzen
Und warum sieht die Seite so kacke aus auf einmal?
Okay, sieht sie nicht
Ja, gibt's direkt, man, come on
Dev-Home is a new Control Center for Windows
Ach, ein neues Control Center
Davon haben wir schon so wenig in Windows 11
Es gibt ja nur acht verschiedene Control Center
Äh, für Windows Pro, to monitor projects in your dashboard using Cass
Hä?
Äh, wozu, was ist der Sinn davon?
Ich meine, wenn ich den Überblick über meine Sachen habe, dann kann ich einfach auf die GitHub-Startseite gehen
Also ich wüsste gar nicht, warum ich da eine Native-Windows-App zu aufmachen sollte
Und SSH-Verbindung manage ich gar nicht unter Windows, sondern habe einfach meine Linux-VM und meine Shell-History
Da ist ein Task-Manager drin?
Who cares?
Hä?
Es gibt einen Link zu GitHub-Issues? Ja gut, aber das...
Okay, so richtig den Sinn davon verstehe ich nicht
Aber die Leute, weiß nicht
Weiß nicht, ob's die Leute feiern
Anscheinend feiern's die Leute
Ich hab den Sinn noch nicht so ganz erkannt
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass ich als meine Hauptentwicklungskiste eh kein Windows verwenden würde
Hat sich das ja schon mal erledigt für mich
Ja, keine Ahnung, was das wieder sein soll
Jetzt ist doch immer noch der gleiche Windows-Account
Du kannst doch Arbeiten und Spielen jetzt auch voneinander trennen
Entweder machst du dir, so wie ich, zwei Windows-Accounts für Streamen und eins für alles andere
Oder du hast eine...
Arbeit und Spiele sind ja in Windows normalerweise getrennt
Das ist ja nicht die gleiche Anwendung
Also, keine Ahnung, was die da...
Ich weiß nicht
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich's mir angucken werde
Windows ist nicht meine Hauptentwicklungskiste und wird's wahrscheinlich auch nicht werden
Insofern sehe ich da jetzt keinen großartigen Sinn dahinter
Guck mal
Ich krieg mein eigenes Video empfohlen
Das ist nice
Das muss ich anklicken
Für mehr Viewtime
Ja, jetzt kann ich mir meine Werkzeugwand angucken
Nice
Wo mir gerade auffällt, dass ich...
Glaub mal, ich muss mir die ganzen Schrauben hier und so wieder zusammensuchen
Da stecken nur noch zwei Stück in der Wand
Vom letzten Chrome-Update sollte Max mit seinen massen Tabs profitieren
Gucken wir doch mal
Chrome
Oh, tatsächlich, ist weniger geworden
Das letzte Mal hatten wir noch 4,5G
Jetzt haben wir nur 2,3G
Also, es hat wohl einiges gebracht, das letzte Chrome-Update
Was Tabs angeht
Stimmt, wir müssten alle Tabs mal neu laden, aber das mach ich jetzt nicht
Gibt's irgendwas Spannendes?
Was verdient ein Flugbegleiter?
Das gucken wir jetzt, ich glaub, das hab ich auch schon offen
Ich würde mal schätzen, jetzt nicht so viel wie ein Pilot, aber auch schon ganz ordentlich
Weil ich mein, du musst den Leuten ja in irgendeiner Art und Weise vergüten
Ja, nennen wir es mal auf der einen Seite die Verantwortung, aber vor allem auch
Dieses ganze, du hast kein Zuhause so richtig, ne
Du bist immer irgendwie unterwegs, sonst wie am Arsch der Welt
Ja, also das ist glaube ich so ein ganz eigener Lebensstil, den man, den muss ja auch irgendwie vergütet werden
Der Fehler Nummer 1 in jeder Präsentation, ok, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Oh, der Niklas ist ein bisschen leise
Woran liegt denn das? Warum ist der so leise?
Weil?
Keine Ahnung
Ähm
Warum gibt es eigentlich keine Lautstärke-Regelung?
Warum gibt es keine Lautstärke-Regelung bei
Bei Shorts?
Das ist keine Lautstärke-Regelung, das ist Mutant & Mutant
Ja, dann können wir uns das nicht angucken, keine Ahnung
Ja, das ist zu, zu minimales Design
Ok, komm, wir gucken uns jetzt an, was man als Flugbegleiter verdient
Trinken, ja, exzellente Idee, Chat
Ende in der Uhr, Shorts durch Watch
Gute Idee
Das war
Wie heißt da nochmal Niklas?
So, glaub, ne
Müssen wir mal bei Shorts gucken, ob wir das finden
So, was ist der Präsentation?
Fehler Nummer 1 in Präsentationen
Ach, jetzt ist die Lautstärke ok, ok
Also, was ist der Nummer 1-Fehler in Präsentationen?
Witzigerweise, ich hab mich gestern ja auch ein bisschen zu dem Thema ausgelassen
Mal gucken, was er sagt, 20 Sekunden
Also, wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach am Anfang, also gerade fürs Intro
So ein bisschen Story erzählen ist gut
So als Aufhänger
Ok, auf geht's
Ok, das stimmt
Würde ich auch nicht machen
Also, würde ich auch nicht empfehlen
So nach dem Motto, ah ja, ich hatte ja erst so kurz Zeit mich dazu beschäftigen
Oder mir ist gerade entfallen, wie das und das heißt
Ich würde die Leute nicht wirklich darauf hinweisen, dass ich keinen Plan hab
Das ist eine schlechte Idee
Das würde ich gar nicht, das ist denen doch eh egal
Also, ich denke aus der USB-Stick-Geschichte
Wenn es nicht kaputt ist, kann man schon irgendwie so während man aufbaut
Noch irgendwie ein bisschen was erzählen
So nach dem Motto, ja, wie es das mal wieder will, ist das Ding kaputt, aber hier
Irgendwas, aber das würde ich auch so sehen, ja
Und möglichst niedrige Erwartungen setzen, um dann hoffentlich mit einem guten Vortrag zu überraschen
Aber das funktioniert nicht
Genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall
Die Leute denken von Anfang an, na toll, das wird ein schlechter Vortrag
Und dann achten die besonders auf die Fehler und finden sie auch
Also so schwer es fällt, tritt selbstbewusst auf
Na klar bist du gut vorbereitet
Ich würde, also, unabhängig davon
Also das, ich würde auch nicht erzählen
Also das würde ich ihm recht geben, das ist bescheuert zu sagen
So nach dem Motto, ey, was weiß ich, ich habe schlecht geschlafen
Und vielleicht fällt mir heute nicht alles ein oder irgendwie sowas
Ja, das ist wirklich keine gute Idee
Zumal nicht nur, dass es die Leute darauf vorbereitet
Dass jetzt irgendwas Mieses kommt
Es ist auch für einen selbst blöd
Wenn man sich erst nochmal einredet, das wird eh nix
Das stimmt, ja
Und wie gesagt, ich finde, ich habe es ja gestern im Stream schon gesagt
Also ich finde, zur Einleitung immer gut, wenn man so eine kleine Story
Wo es die Leute reinversetzen kann, erzählen kann
Keine fünf Minuten, sondern so als Aufhänger
Ja, man sitzt nachts da, alle Systeme gehen kaputt
Und dann bla bla bla, was auch immer
Irgendwas, was halt dazu passt
Und als Outro finde ich blöd, dieses Vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Da würde ich immer irgendwas anderes sagen
Ansonsten, denke ich, muss man da irgendeinen Stil finden, der zu einem passt
So, also, wir wollten uns jetzt ja den Flugbegleiter angucken
An einem Tag nach Mallorca und zurück
Warum heißt es eigentlich Mallorca und man schreibt es Malorca?
Wie hat sich das ausgedacht?
Vielleicht heißt es ja auch gar nicht Mallorca
Und es heißt eigentlich Malorca
Weil es nicht Deutsch ist, wie jetzt
Ich dachte es ist Deutsch
Da fahren doch immer auch nur Deutsche in Urlaub hin
Die Comments, Alter
Wie süß ist er bitte?
Okay, zeigt mal her
Also, an einem Tag Mallorca, was verdient ein Flugbegleiter?
Willkommen an Bord
Prost
Ich glaube, Lautstärke passt
Wir können kein Bargeld mehr annehmen
Kein Bargeld
Ich hoffe, man kann mit Karte kontaktlos bezahlen
Ist, dass Leute ganz schnell ihr Gesicht ändern können
Ich finde mein Gehalt gut
Aber es gibt echt Monate, wo ich mir dann denke, ja, hätte auch mehr sein können
Das denke ich mir auch öfters
Aber nicht, weil es wirklich so wenig ist, sondern es kann eigentlich immer mehr sein
Das wird sich wahrscheinlich sogar, frag mich nicht, Jeff Bezos, gerade der, wird sich das auch monatlich denken
Ist ja eigentlich ganz nice, aber es könnte ja auch mehr sein
Lass mal gucken, dass wir bei Prime Subs plus noch 40% an die Creator abgeben
Easy Money
Hi, ich bin Joel, ich bin Flugbegleiter in Berlin und ich nehme euch heute mal mit auf einen Flug
Der macht aber wirklich einen äußerst gut gelaunten Eindruck
Vom beliebtesten Reiseziel, das, was wir in Deutschland haben
Lautstärke ist okay, oder? Ich muss gerade mal gucken
Ja, ist okay, weil es ist das erste Video, was ich heute angemacht habe
Da bist du dann auch wieder zu Hause, wenn es noch hell ist
Gerade so kurze Flüge, da fliegen wir von Berlin nach Köln, wieder zurück, dann nochmal nach Düsseldorf und wieder zurück
Dann kannst du schon vier Flüge haben, im Schnitt so 10-11 Stunden am Tag
Oh, hallo
10-11 Stunden am Tag, da hast du ganz schön was zu tun
Wobei die dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht jeden Tag, also die werden wahrscheinlich auch keine 5-Tage-Woche haben, oder?
Weil das wären ja dann irgendwie 55-55 Wochenstunden
Hallo, guten Morgen
Die arbeiten wahrscheinlich auch noch vier Tage und dann müssen sie sich mal ein bisschen ausruhen
Lieber, alles gut?
Das mag ich ja überhaupt nicht, dieses Abgeknutsche, Alter, da kriege ich Anfälle
Da mache ich dann immer zwei Schritte zurück und lasse mich nicht abknuten
Hand geben ist ja okay, aber dieses Küsschen links und rechts, das finde ich immer ganz abartig
Kuhraum rein, der ist einmal oben da in dem Gebäude und da treffen wir gleich die Crew, drucken unsere Unterlagen aus
Morgen, hi, du bist Can, ne? Ja, genau
Also Crews wechseln immer durch, mal fliegt man mehrere Tage am Stück zusammen, mal nicht
Ja, das ist unterschiedlich, mal fliegt man auch zusammen und sieht man sich nach sechs Monaten, sieben Monaten wieder
Also das Flugzeug für heute, die Zeiten sind noch alle pünktlich, 180 kann das Flugzeug und 180 sind verkauft
180 Sitzplätze, oder was? Wahrscheinlich
Voll hin und 160 zurück
Briefing ist jeden Morgen, das findet vor jedem Tag statt, nicht vor jedem Flug, ne?
Hallo, herzlich willkommen
Alter, die sind ja alle so gut drauf, ist das Unternehmenspolicy, Positivität ausstrahlen oder sind die wirklich alle so gut drauf?
Flug nach Palma, wie wollt ihr dann fliegen?
Wenn es okay ist, fährt gerne 3L
Ja, ich würde dann auf die 3R gehen
Alles klar, gut
Die Aufgaben sind ja auf jeder Position auch ein bisschen anders, irgendwann hat man da seine Lieblingsposition rausgefunden
Dann, medizinisch, ist euch in letzter Zeit irgendwas passiert, worüber ihr reden wollt?
Nichts Dramatisches, nur Bewusstlosigkeit halt, die hat einfach nichts gegessen, war krank
Achso, ich dachte es geht um die Leute selbst, das ist okay, das habe ich falsch verstanden
Ich habe jetzt gedacht, die reden darüber, ob sie irgendwie selbst gesundheitliche Probleme haben, was Probleme beim Flug machen könnte
Und das erste, was man hört, ist so, ach, nichts besonderes, ich werde nur ab und zu mal bewusstlos
Nein, es ging da drum, dass er wohl in einem Flug war, wo jemand bewusstlos geworden ist
Das passiert wahrscheinlich öfters mal, das kann ich mir vorstellen
Nur Bewusstlosigkeit halt, die hat einfach nichts gegessen, war kreislaufist
Ich glaube, jetzt sind viele Eltern auch bei, die einfach so einen Familienurlaub machen
Das ist aber auch immer von Wochentag zu Wochentag sogar unterschiedlich
Du hast einmal die Passagiere, die nur einmal im Jahr verreisen, für die ist das alles ganz spannend und aufregend und die wollen auch alles ganz genau wissen
Dann hast du die Passagiere, die zum Feiern wegfliegen, denen ist eigentlich alles egal
Die sind wahrscheinlich schon besoffen, bevor sie einsteigen
Geschäftsreisende ist auch nochmal eine besondere Klasse, einfach weil die diesen Zeitdruck auch haben
Ich finde manchmal Geschäftsreisende anstrengend
Nein, das ist diese Mischung, die ist cool
Deswegen, wie gesagt, Palmerflüge mache ich am liebsten, weil da hast du alles drauf
Willkommen an Bord, also wir gehen einmal nach hinten durch, ich arbeite hinten heute
Es gibt auch keinen schlecht gelaunten Radiomoderator
Okay, ich kann dir jetzt nicht direkt widersprechen, aber ich hatte bei der alten Arbeit einen Kollegen, der hatte früher, keine Ahnung wie der zu IT gekommen ist
Also wir hatten da teilweise schon aus allen Richtungen Leute
Ich hatte auf der alten Arbeit einen Kollegen, der hatte früher in Hamburg eine Hip-Hop Sendung in einem lokalen Hamburger Radio
Und ich glaube, da war der nicht so gut drauf jedes Mal
Der hat auch immer ganz gerne mal ein bisschen gemeckert
Und ich vermute mal, das hat er als Radiomoderator auch gemacht
Aber nein, ich kann dir kein selbstgehörtes Gegenbeispiel dazu nehmen, du hast schon recht
Die werden dafür bezahlt, gut drauf zu sein
Ich mache jetzt meinen Check, da will ich jetzt auch schon anfangen, weil wir müssen uns ein bisschen beeilen
Feuer an Bord kann natürlich passieren, das ist natürlich das Schlimmste, was wir haben können
Jetzt im Moment viele Laptops, Handys, Akkus sind drin
Habt ihr übrigens mitbekommen, dass AirTags mittlerweile erlaubt sind, by the way
Es gab ja eine Zeit lang die Diskussion, AirTags wegen Lithium-Ionen-Akkus und so dürfen nicht ins Gepäck
Mittlerweile dürfen AirTags ins Gepäck
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das bei den Amis heißt, denen ihre Flugaufsicht, da hat das erlaubt
Die europäische Flugaufsicht und so haben das auch erlaubt
Und Lufthansa hat es glaube ich mittlerweile auch offiziell erlaubt
Also man kann AirTags in Gepäck packen
Wenn du mit den Türen umgehst, das ganze Equipment, wo was gestaut ist
Notfälle umzugehen, Brandbekämpfung, siehst du alles in der Ausbildung
Die Ausbildungszeit ist von Airline zu Airline unterschiedlich
Bei Eurowings sind es eben sechs Wochen
Zum Beispiel eine Lufthansa hat zwölf Wochen Schulung
Also lernst du da wirklich alles
Was? Das reicht? Wirklich?
In sechs Wochen ist man fertig? Krass, das hätte ich nicht gedacht
Also in zwölf Wochen? Ich hatte gedacht, da machst du irgendwie ein halbes Jahr, ein Jahr oder so Ausbildung
Bist du da alles durch? Okay
Na gut, die Leute haben wahrscheinlich, ja gut, ne wobei, ne
Er hat Bürokaufmann für Büromanagement
Ja, ist das nicht früher anders?
Ist das nicht früher Kaufmann für Büroorganisation?
Oder ist das wieder was anderes?
Von der Pike auf, musst du aber schon echt dabei sein
Weil da ja auch immer Tests geschrieben worden sind
Und die darfst du nicht vergessen
Kevin, Pre-Flight-Check-Computer
Vielen Dank
So, zwei Stunden zehn hin, zurück, zwei Stunden dreißig
Wärmer-Turbulenzen bringen dann etwa nach einer dreiviertel Stunde
Ja, München-Endaum, jeder zeigt gerne an uns
Frohes Schaffen, ne? Weil wir müssen uns schon ein bisschen sputen
Wir sind nämlich von der Dienstzeit britisch, ne?
Ja
Wir können mehr arbeiten und länger arbeiten wie jetzt in einem klassischen Job
Aber wir haben natürlich auch Limitierungen
Und haben dann auch die Möglichkeit, dass wir uns ein bisschen spüren
Wir haben Limitierungen und haben dafür, dass wir so lange Arbeitszeiten haben
Was ist denn ein AirTag?
So ein Teil von Apple, wo man Sachen mit tracken kann
Kann man ins Gepäck machen, da kannst du dann mit deinem iPhone gucken, wo der Standort deines Gepäcks ist
Das funktioniert irgendwie so, dass die Dinger per, ich glaube, Bluetooth oder so ist es
BLE, Bluetooth Low Energy, dass die ab und zu mal so einen Puls aussenden
Und alle iPhones in der Nähe diesen Puls aufnehmen und weiterleiten an Apple
Und nachdem es so viele iPhones auf der Welt gibt, klappt das eigentlich ganz gut
Und dann kriegst du den Standort von deinem Gepäck
Eigentlich eine ganz sinnige Sache
Strenge Ruhezeiten
Hallo
Ja, 180 sind wir, wir sind heute volle Hütte
Gerne, wenn Sie die Windel wechseln wollen, wir haben hinten zwei Wickeltische, können Sie sich runterklappen, aber dass Sie die Windel vorher hier rein machen, ja?
Super
So, alle drin, war jetzt ein bisschen stressig, aber
Der macht wirklich einen äußerst gut gelaunten Eindruck den ganzen Tag
Sind jetzt alle da
So
Crosscheck
Joel, 3R, rear doors in flight
So, erstmal einen schönen guten Morgen und herzlich willkommen an Bord, mein Name ist Christian Klemann, ich bin der Kapitän auf diesem Flug
Wissen Sie da auch immer noch diese, das sind, so funktioniert die Rettungsweste und sowas, macht man das immer noch am Anfang von so einem Flug?
Ich bin schon eine Weile nicht mal geflogen
Sie haben es eventuell schon registriert, wir haben ein TV-Team an Bord vom Bayerischen Rundfunk, das begleitet unseren Kollegen hier in der Hinterras Küche, den Joel
Also für die meisten, die einsteigen, stehe ich halt so da, sag nett Hallo, sag nett auch Wiedersehen und verkaufe denen dann Kaffee
Und das ist auch so die Erwartungshaltung, wir sind Kellner in den Lüften für manche, aber das sind wir halt nicht
Also Flugbegleiter ist wirklich, ich muss mich wirklich darum kümmern, dass der Passagier
Doch guck, Weste
Da ist doch Weste am Start
Passagieren von A nach B kommen, sicher und heil
Direkt, direkt, chat, direkt, debunked
Dann, ich bin durch, dann war es das, ist alles zu
Bevor wir abheben, gehen wir einfach nochmal so Sachen durch, falls irgendwann
Ich muss ja sagen, es sieht äußerst unbequem aus, hier zu hocken
Bevor wir abheben, gehen wir einfach nochmal so Sachen durch, falls irgendwas sein sollte, unsere Kommandos
Ja, dass wir uns einfach nochmal auf uns konzentrieren, wie wir jetzt starten, in welche Richtung
Ich wollte immer fliegen, seit ich das erste Mal im Flugzeug war, fand ich das so faszinierend
Ich liebe die Flugzeuge, ich liebe die Technik, die dahinter steckt
Das Starten, das Landen, das über den Wolken sein, die Sonnenaufgänge
Ich liebe die Technik, die dahinter steckt, das Starten, das Landen, das über den Wolken sein, die Sonnenaufgänge
Jetzt geht's gleich los, genau
Guckt euch das mal an, das ist tatsächlich mal wieder ein Video von jemand, der den ganzen Tag auch was macht für sein Geld
Nicht so wie diese komische Unternehmensberaterin, die drei Zeilen Excel am Tag eingetragen hat
und das als die hohe Kunst verkauft hat
Nein, Platzgangs darfst du nicht haben
Und du musst es mögen, mit Leuten hier hinten zu kuscheln oder vorne, weil du kommst nicht drumrum
Möchten Sie was aus der Karte bestellen?
Ich kann leider nur Kartenzahlung annehmen
Wir können kein Bargeld mehr annehmen
Ich kann Ihnen sonst alternativ ein Becher Wasser bringen, wenn Sie das möchten
Ich übergebe Ihnen einen Kaffee und einen Bier
Ja, machen Sie das? Okay, super, vielen Dank
Dann schönen Urlaub, ja?
Möchten Sie den Prosecco auf Eis haben?
Ein Prosecco auf Eis, im Flugzeug, im Becher
Also mal ganz davon absehen, ich würde es gar nicht trinken
Ist das zum Nerven beruhigen, oder wie?
Also ich bin immer gern geflogen, es ergibt sich in letzter Zeit allerdings nicht oft
Also, zu was sollte ich fliegen?
Das letzte, was ich ergeben hätte, wo ich dann aber tatsächlich mit der Bahn gefahren bin, war
Ich würde gerne ein Bier trinken
nach
Ich glaube nach Berlin
Damals noch zu einem Battlefield-Event, wo sie, mittlerweile laden die mich ja auch nicht mehr ein, verständlicherweise
Da habe ich aber auch gesagt, es spart mir überhaupt nichts, da irgendwie mit dem Flieger hin zu fliegen
Es ergibt sich in letzter Zeit wenig, aber
Also ich bin sonst auch immer sehr gerne geflogen
Ich finde Flugzeuge an sich interessant, das Fliegen finde ich irgendwie immer aufregend und toll
Also das ist nice
Ist nice, ja
Machst du nie Urlaub?
Nö, mache ich nicht
Mein Urlaub ist
Komplett im Dezember nicht arbeiten gehen und in der Zeit YouTube und Twitch-Zeug machen
Das ist tatsächlich mein Urlaub die letzten Jahre über
Und ja, montags
Montags habe ich immer frei und mache Urlaub, in Anführungsstrichen Urlaub
Allerdings das ist nirgendwo, wo man direkt hinfliegt für einen Tag
Ne, ich bin schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr geflogen, aber ich bin immer gerne geflogen
Immer alles abbauen und verräumen
Ja, tatsächlich jetzt eher, hätte ich nicht gedacht, also eher so auch ältere Leute
Eher ruhig, eher ruhiges Publikum heute
Ich selber hatte jetzt noch keine Situation, da wo wirklich was jetzt groß eskaliert wäre, außer an dem Tag mit der Verspätung
Vier Stunden waren wir an Bord mit Passagieren, das war wegen Unwetter und wegen hohem Flugverkehr
Ich fand krass diese Bedrohung, dass ein Passagier zu mir gekommen ist, die ganze Zeit am Telefon mit seinem Anwalt
Und mich wirklich in die Enge da getrieben hat, das war für mich, ich dachte erst
Mit dem Anwalt, so nach dem Wort, ich verklage, ich verklag sie
Schlimmste Tag gewesen, aber gleichzeitig im Nachhinein muss ich auch sagen, mit so der Beste
Weil ich auch über mich so richtig raus gekommen bin
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn du dir die Zugbegleiter in der Bahn anscheißt, weil die Bahn Verspätung hat
Die bekommen es leider oftmals ab, die können da aber gar nichts dafür
Ich bin da nicht ganz frei von, ich hab mich sicherlich auch schon das ein oder andere Mal aufgeregt
Aber ich hab nie jetzt quasi drauf gewartet, so wenn der Zugbegleiter jetzt kommt, dann scheiße ich ihn an oder so
Was ich immer ganz gerne mache, ist auf Twitter die Leute von der Bahn beleidigen, die können ja eigentlich auch nichts dafür
Ich schreibe das dann auch meistens dahinter, noch eine zweite Nachricht
Ich weiß, dass ihr vom Social Media Team auf Twitter nichts dafür könnt, aber trotzdem alles Kackspasten
Also Leute, die Bahn beleidigen auf Twitter mach ich auch ganz gerne
Auch wenn es teilweise da schon auch die Leute trifft, die nichts dafür können
Also zur Landung und zum Start ist es halt so, dass wir die Uniform komplett haben
Wenn wir in eine Notsituation kommen, dass wir uns von den Passagieren eben unterscheiden
Wie wir ausziehen, da wird natürlich drauf geachtet
Wart mal, das hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden, was?
Also zur Landung und zum Start ist es halt so, dass wir die Uniform komplett haben
Ah, jetzt hab ich es verstanden
Wenn wir in eine Notsituation kommen, dass wir uns von den Passagieren eben unterscheiden
Wie wir aussehen, da wird natürlich drauf geachtet, weil die Uniform hat ja auch eine Wirkung.
Wir können jetzt selber keine Tattoos tragen oder auch keine besonderen Frisuren.
Ein dezentes Make-up muss getragen werden, das wird auch vorausgesetzt bei Kolleginnen.
Naja, man verdient ja schon ein bisschen auch sein Geld damit, dass man optisch ein bisschen was hermacht.
Ist doch gut, wenn man das von Anfang an weiß.
Da sind wir.
Joel, 3R, Realdorsen Park.
Wir stehen jetzt an einer Fingerposition, das heißt, die Gäste steigen alle vorne nur aus.
Wenn ich das so sehe, fällt mir ein, ich muss mal wieder zum Friseur.
Jetzt einmal schnell durchgehen, alles wieder sauber machen und dann kommen die neuen Leute und dann geht's wieder nach Berlin zurück.
35 Minuten ist geplante Bodenzeit.
Wir sind aber ein bisschen zu spät, deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt echt ein bisschen strecken.
So, wollen wir denn gleich anfangen?
Hopp, hopp, hopp.
Da hast du was zu tun, wenn du erst mal 180 Sitze kontrollieren darfst in, keine Ahnung, 20 Minuten.
Also wir sind ja gerade angekommen.
Okay, sind auch drei Leute.
Alles frisch gemacht und dann wieder weg.
Das ist wirklich nicht so, dass ich viel jetzt sehe von der Welt oder von Europa.
Wo ich aber doch viel halt schon sehen kann, ist, dass ich ja auch selber wegfliegen kann.
Die Airlines haben untereinander so ein Abkommen.
Ich komme nur mit, wenn auch noch Platz ist.
Aber die Tickets sind halt günstiger, wirklich günstiger.
Das ist natürlich cool, wenn man sowas gerne macht.
Egal und das lohnt sich halt schon.
Hallo.
Ja, wenn man gerne irgendwo hinfliegt und bei einer Airline arbeitet, dann kann man es natürlich auch nutzen.
Das ist natürlich nice.
Alter, die Musik im Hintergrund.
Was geht jetzt ab?
Übertreibt halt.
Neue Runde.
So.
Einen oder je einen?
Ne, ist für eine Freundin.
Ja, sie hat 30. gefeiert.
Wir waren fünf Tage in Afrika mit 30 Leuten.
Die sind doch auch noch ein bisschen besoffen, oder?
Ja, wie in Wien mäßig oder wie?
Ein schönes Buffet und viel Party.
Da ist noch ein bisschen Restlevel im Blut.
Nein, nein, da ist Mutter mit Kind.
Die hatten gebraucht.
Das Kind hat gebraucht.
Genau, schauen Sie mal.
Ich hole Ihnen mal Tücher noch.
Da ist alles voll, hat sie gesagt.
Wir sind für die Passagiere Servicekraft, wir sind Ärztehilfe, wir sind Ärzte, Krankenschwestern.
Wir sind Psychologen.
Einmal die Tücher hier zur Landung wieder nach oben klappen.
Wo ich angefangen habe, hatte ich natürlich ein bisschen Angst gehabt.
Da ging die ganze Situation in der Ukraine los.
Und da hatte ich dann mir gedacht, okay, ist das jetzt vielleicht doch nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt?
Wie entwickelt sich das alles jetzt?
Aber wenn ich wirklich sehe, die Flugzeuge sind voll, die Leute wollen reisen,
fliegen ist teurer geworden, aber die Leute fliegen trotzdem.
Ja, es hat sich ja auch jetzt dank Corona, also es ist ja überwunden, zumindest im Sommer jetzt,
hat sich das ja auch alles ein bisschen entspannt.
Da war schon viel Chaos auch die letzten Jahre über, eben gerade was Flugbetrieb und sowas angeht.
Ich denke, jetzt machen halt auch ganz viele Leute Urlaub, weil sie die letzten paar Jahre nicht richtig konnten.
Macht mir das keiner Angst.
Wie man so schön sagt, eine Haftlandung ist eine gute Landung und damit herzlich willkommen auf dem Flughafen.
Was für eine Landung ist eine gute Landung?
Wie man so schön sagt, eine Haftlandung ist eine...
Eine, eine, eine was? Eine Haftlandung?
Ach, eine harte Landung ist eine... das hätte ich so nicht verstanden.
Eine harte Landung ist eine gute Landung.
Chat, könnt von ausgehen, bzw. die Branche freut sich sicherlich drüber, dass die Flieger voll sind.
Money.
Eine gute Landung und damit herzlich willkommen auf dem Flughafen.
Eine gute Landung und damit herzlich willkommen auf dem Flughafen von Berlin-Frankfurt.
Wiedersehen. Tschüss.
Tschüss. Wiederschauen.
Die Maschine geht ja jetzt weiter.
Cleaning ist jetzt auch schon da, die machen jetzt auch schon sauber.
Und dann gehen wir durch den Passagierausgang mit dem Crewbus auch raus und haben dann Feierabend.
Dann, meine Liebe, schön war's. Dankeschön.
Und dieses Geküsse, Alter, da würde ich Anfälle kriegen.
Tschüss.
Wir sind zusammen, wenn du kannst.
Tschüss, danke dir.
Also ich fahre jetzt direkt zu mir, der Bus fährt direkt durch.
Also wenn ich nach Hause komme, erstmal alles ausziehen, ist zwar schön.
Gut, ich meine, dass der keine super krasse Wohnung und Haus und sonst was hat, ist ja irgendwie klar.
Ich meine, der braucht es schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Der ist so selten wahrscheinlich daheim.
... sieht zwar schön aus, aber einfach den Engkragen aufmachen, die Krawatte abnehmen.
Ich habe sonst immer mit meiner Mutter zusammen gewohnt, gehaft und immer nur in meinem Zimmer da drinnen.
Und dachte mir ja, okay, jetzt erste Wohnung, aber ich habe es natürlich gemacht für einen Job.
Ich finde es super.
Das ist mein bestes Stück, meine Kaffeemaschine, die ich mir gekauft habe.
Schon wieder so einer mit einer super geilen High End.
Na, wobei, die ist nicht ganz so krass.
Die anderen zwei Typen, wo man geguckt hat, die hatten doch alle so eine 10.000 Euro Kaffeemaschine bei sich daheim.
Das ist ja noch irgendwie halbwegs normal.
Das Wichtigste.
Ja, die habe ich mir gewöhnt.
Die musste sein.
Ist doch noch voll im Rahmen.
Komm rein.
Ja, es lohnt sich.
Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Ich liebe den Job und wie ich auch im Privaten leben kann, was ich alles sehe, wie ich reisen kann, wie ich leben kann, was dann noch dazukommt.
Bin gespannt, was am Ende rauskommt.
Echt lernen, mit umzugehen.
Und er?
Ja und er?
Das bisherige Durchschnitt ist, wo es wiederum Unterschiede gibt,
Es gibt ja da Unterschiede.
Das ist jetzt nicht sonderlich viel.
Das schwankt, dass es mal mehr ist, mal weniger.
Flaschenöffner habe ich am Schlüssel dran.
Soll ich uns diese Decke mitnehmen?
Ich hab die jetzt einfach mal eingepackt.
Lass uns unterwegs was holen.
Ich hab Lust auf Domo.
Ich fliege im Juni mit Marvin nach Malle mit der Hamsa, mit der 747, die Crew in Frankfurt.
Erstmal ne Runde Döner genehmigen.
Ich bin glücklich.
Das ist doch die Hauptsache.
Scheiß drauf.
Super krass Gehalt und nicht gut drauf.
Kack Atmosphäre und doofe Arbeit.
Wenn er glücklich ist, ist das unterm Strich das Wichtigste.
Der macht auch echt einen super happy Eindruck.
Ich wäre absolut nicht glücklich in dieser Position.
Weil der ist den ganzen Tag dabei mit irgendwelchen Mitmenschen zu interagieren.
Das wäre für mich der blanke Horror.
Aber für ihn scheint das genau das Richtige zu sein.
Das ist halt wirklich, ich hätte gedacht es ist mehr.
Das ist jetzt wirklich nicht viel.
Also 2100 Euro im Monat quasi überwiesen bekommen aufs Konto.
Das ist schon nicht die Welt.
Aber gut, wenn er glücklich ist, oder scheint er seinen Job auch gern zu machen, ist das ja alles ganz nice.
Aber ich hätte ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen mehr gerechnet.
So YouTube, empfiehlst du uns noch irgendwas?
Alter macht MrBeast krass viele Views die ersten 24 Stunden.
17 Millionen in 10 Stunden.
Das ist schon heftig.
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile der größte YouTube Channel?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, den kenne ich.
Nicht dass ich den jetzt verwechsle, aber ich glaube es ist Simplicissimus.
Die Videos haben so einen gewissen rhetorischen Aufbau.
Dass du immer denkst, jetzt kommt gleich die große Enthüllung oder der große Twist oder der große Höhepunkt vom Video.
Und dann geht es immer wieder, kommt dann gar nichts.
Und so geht das bis zum Ende hin.
Bei den ganzen Videos von Simplicissimus denkst du immer so, jede Minute, jetzt kommt ein cooler, interessanter...
Genau, das meine ich.
Das habe ich versucht zu beschreiben gerade.
Ja, das trifft es ganz gut.
Jetzt sagt er was.
Passiert wieder.
Ne, finde ich jetzt nicht so doll die Videos.
Ich habe die am Anfang öfters auch mal im Stream geguckt.
Aber es ist halt die gleiche Aufmachung jedes Mal und eigentlich kommt relativ wenig rum dabei.
Und ihn kann ich mir ja auch nicht mehr angucken.
Weil viele von den Videos sind so, eigentlich könntest du es in 30 Sekunden packen.
Okay, da darf ich nichts sagen.
Vieles von meinem Inhalt kann man auch in 30 Sekunden packen.
Und ich labere 15 Minuten drüber.
Ich glaube, das ist auf YouTube, das muss einfach so sein.
Ich glaube, das ist ja auch eines der Punkte, warum Firechip so erfolgreich ist, was Technikvideos angeht.
Der macht quasi TLDR-Videos.
2 Minuten 30 und packt das voll mit allem möglichen Zeug, wo andere eine halbe Stunde gezeigt hätten.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Wie viele Tabs willst du offen haben?
Ja, Moment, ich habe hier Tabs offen, ich habe da Tabs offen, ich habe da und in der Vorhinein auch noch Tabs offen.
Kannst du die Tabs auch gruppieren? Ja.
Man kann viel, wenn man denn will.
Nee, ich habe gesehen, der hat vorhin, glaube ich, sogar eins hochgeladen.
Irgendetwas mit...
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ich habe vorhin, glaube ich, sogar eines hochgeladen.
Irgendwas mit..
antikememz, oder sowas.
K.I.
Photoshop, ist der Wahnsinn.
Okay, K.I. Photoshop.
Ich guck die Videos ja immer gar gern.
Wobei ich schaun muss, die Themen sind mir etwas zu
die Themen sind mir etwas zu
AI- earthy, in letzter Zeit.
Du kannst vielleicht alle Videos parallel schauen.
Sehr gute Idee.
Ich glaube, das sollten wir beachten.
Wir gucken uns jetzt, weiß nicht wie viele Tabs, das sind 30 Videos parallel an.
Easy Tipp zum Zeitsparen.
Nicht nur parallel, alle Videos parallel auf 1,5 facher Geschwindigkeit.
Next Level Idee Chat.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
KI Photoshop.
Ist ChatGPT viel besser als sein Vorgänger?
Ja, ist es.
Wir probieren es ja ab und zu hier im Streamer immer mit kleinen Sachen aus.
Da ist trotzdem, es ist auch viel Schwachsinn dabei.
Wir haben letztens zum Beispiel mal ChatGPT gefragt, ob sie uns nicht oder ich weiß nicht,
was haben wir gefragt?
Ach genau, ich weiß es wieder.
Wie man in .NET mit dem Standard-HTTP-Client eine Progressbar hinbekommt.
Und da hat ChatGPT einfach Methoden hinzu erfunden, die der HTTP-Client angeblich hat.
Sowas wie onProgress und sowas.
Die hat er gar nicht.
Die gibt es überhaupt nicht.
ChatGPT hat einfach so getan, als gäbe es die.
Also es hat nicht funktioniert.
Und dazu kam, dass es irgendwie was für Windows Forms gebaut hat, ganz weird.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist ein Selfie von mir aus Paris, komplett unbearbeitet.
Jetzt lade ich das in die Photoshop-Beta, ziehe einfach so ein Auswahlrechteck grob über mein T-Shirt.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist ein Selfie von mir aus Paris, komplett unbearbeitet.
Jetzt lade ich das in die Photoshop-Beta, ziehe einfach so ein Auswahlrechteck grob über mein T-Shirt.
Also ohne Freistellung und nix, einfach nur ein Rechteck.
Und jetzt tippe ich hier ein Tuxedo, also Smoking.
Zack, generieren, habe ich ein Smoking an.
Und kann sogar noch unterschiedliche Varianten durchführen.
Nicht schlecht.
Und das sieht besser aus, als irgendwelche Fiverr Photoshop-Leute zur Bearbeitung.
Ich meine, ein bisschen erkennst du es schon, auch von der Beleuchtung her und sowas.
Aber das ist nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe hier keine Schritte übersprungen.
Wir haben nur die Generierungszeit etwas beschleunigt.
Lass doch mal den Eiffelturm durch den Turm von Pisa ersetzen.
Einfach grob auswählen, Tower auf Pisa eingeben, zack, fertig.
Ziemlich krass, oder?
Das ist aber noch längst nicht alles, was Adobe an KI-Funktionen inzwischen eingebaut hat.
Nicht schlecht.
Man kann in Premiere zum Beispiel jetzt per Texteingabe Video editieren.
Wir haben uns das alles mal genauer angesehen.
Bleibt dran und abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Wisst ihr ja.
Video editieren durch Texteingabe?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es einfach schneller geht, das zu editieren, anstatt es in den Text zu schreiben.
Okay.
Genauer angesehen.
Bleibt dran und abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Wisst ihr ja.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internetsurfer, herzlich willkommen hier.
Bye.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von 3CX.
Okay.
Adobe bietet ja schon seit längerem so ein KI-Bildgenerierungstool an.
Firefly heißt das.
Habt ihr das schon mal benutzt?
Ich habe bis eben noch gar nicht gewusst, dass das existiert.
Einfach im Browser auf firefly.adobe.com gehen.
Und ja, das macht das gleiche wie mit Journey, Stable Diffusion und Dally.
Okay.
Man gibt irgendwas ein, Affe auf dem Einrad, zack, fertig ist das Bild.
Das Besondere an Adobe Firefly, es ist mit Bildern aus Adobe...
Okay.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Firefly?
Gibt es erst seit drei Tagen, ach so.
Firefly Adobe.
AI Art Generator.
Okay.
Kann ich jetzt was eingeben?
Ich glaube, mein Darkreader macht komisches Zeug.
Technik.
Text-to-Image Generate.
Muss man sich da registrieren für, oder?
Äh.
Okay.
Braucht man Adobe Cloud?
Abo.
Okay.
Weil ansonsten hätte ich es mal ausprobiert irgendwie.
L Resitas im Schwimmbad oder irgendwas.
Keine Ahnung.
Guckt, was da rausgekommen wäre.
Hätte ich jetzt mal ausprobiert, aber geht ja anscheinend nicht.
Äh, wo ist es denn, wenn ich hier stehen geblieben bin?
Äh.
Hä?
Ach, ich hatte das schon offen.
Was sagt ihr jetzt?
Sollte man als Unternehmen so schnell wie möglich die Prozesse an AI anpassen?
Keine Ahnung.
Im Zweifelsfall.
Erst mal gucken.
Wie und wo das sinnvoll ist, anstatt.
Das fängt ja schon an mit.
Was ist damit überhaupt gemeint?
Ja.
Was soll das überhaupt bedeuten?
Die Prozesse an AI anpassen?
Keine Ahnung.
Man soll sich Gedanken machen, anstatt.
Bevor man auf irgendeinen Hype-Train aufspringt.
Ich habe dieses Mal auf der Photodatenbank trainiert.
Und Adobe verspricht, die generierten Bilder können problemlos kommerziell verwendet werden.
Es besteht kein Risiko für irgendwelche Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Bei der Konkurrenz ist die Datenlage etwas unklarer.
Da gibt es immer wieder Kreative, die ihre Bilder oder Teile davon in den neuen generierten Bildern entdecken.
Aber generell.
Firefly funktioniert genauso wie mit Journey oder mit Google.
neuen, generierten Bildern entdecken. Aber generell, Firefly funktioniert genauso wie
Midjourney oder Stable Diffusion. Aber was jetzt neu ist, Adobe hat die Firefly-KI-Technik
direkt in ihre Software eingebaut. Zuerst mal in Photoshop, also in der Beta-Version,
die können aber alle hin...
Das ist jetzt auch so ein global-galaktisches Thema, oder?
Was ist deine Meinung zum Thema? Und die Leute, die dir das Fliegen deswegen verbieten...
Also erstens, mir verbietet ja keiner das Fliegen deswegen. Es gibt Leute, denen schwebt
das vor. Es gibt auch Leute, denen schwebt vor, dass man nicht mehr mit den Autos in
die Innenstädte fahren darf, ohne irgendwie ernsthafte Alternativen dazu zu haben. So
zum Beispiel, wie Leute auf die Arbeit kommen sollen gescheit. Oder vielleicht sich zu überlegen,
sobald es sinnvolle Alternativen gibt, wie ordentlich ausgebauten Nahverkehr, erst dann
sowas zu machen. Ja, es schwirrt ja relativ viel rum. Also, ich denke, das ist eines der
größten... Wie sagt man so schön? Es gibt ja keine Probleme, es gibt nur Herausforderungen.
Das ist eine der größten Herausforderungen, die wir aktuell haben und die wir auch die
nächsten Jahrzehnte haben werden. Allerdings denke ich auch, dass wir nicht die Welt retten
können, hier alleine bei uns. Und wenn wir es zu sehr übertreiben, dass wir in Folge
von Klimawandelbekämpfung die falschen Entscheidungen treffen, also sprich, dass wir unterm Strich
quasi unseren... Also es wird ja, ich muss das anders sagen, es wird ja oft gesagt so
nach dem Motto, die Leute sind nicht bereit, für das Klima auf Sachen zu verzichten. Das
mag schon sein. Ich denke, viele sind bereit, auf was zu verzichten, wenn es sinnvolle Alternativen
gibt. Aber so nach dem Motto, wir verbieten jetzt was, ohne dass es Alternativen gibt,
das ist, glaube ich, das, was vielen ein bisschen sauer aufstößt. Ich denke, dass man vieles
freiwillig macht, wenn die Alternativen da sind. Aber diese Geschichte mit, ja, die Leute,
die wollen ja von ihrem Reichtum nichts einbüßen, um für den Klimawandel was zu machen, ich
glaube, das ist ein Trugschluss. Weil, wenn man jetzt sagt, uns muss es schlechter gehen,
oder wir müssen halt ganz viel ausgeben und ganz viel machen dafür, so dass es uns unterm
Strich schlechter geht. Ich glaube, dann sorgen wir nicht dafür, dass es insgesamt besser
wird. Weil, wenn wir jetzt mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen, das ist ja sowas, was immer gebracht
wird, so nach dem Motto, wir haben die Technologie, wir haben das Geld, was wir ja auch haben.
Technologie vielleicht nicht, aber zumindest mal das Geld, was zu machen. Und wenn man
jetzt zeigt, okay, wir gehen mit gutem Beispiel voran, aber wir werden, uns geht es schlechter
dadurch, dass wir mit gutem Beispiel vorangegangen sind, dann wird wahrscheinlich keiner wirklich
mitmachen. Ich meine, meinte irgendjemand, würde sich daran orientieren, wenn wir sagen,
wir setzen jetzt diese Richtlinie, diese Sachen um. Gut, hat dazu geführt, viel besser, alles
hier weniger CO2-Ausschuss, weniger Umweltverschmutzung, alles. Aber unterm Strich geht es den Leuten
im Durchschnitt viel schlechter, wohlstandstechnisch. Das macht ja keiner mit. Das ist dann weniger
mit gutem Beispiel vorangegangen, das ist vielleicht für Schadstoffausstoße mit gutem
Beispiel vorangegangen, aber es ist nicht mit gutem Beispiel vorangegangen, dass uns
das irgendjemand nachmachen würde. Warum sollte uns das irgendjemand nachmachen, wenn
man nur sieht, guckt mal, Deutschland hat es probiert, sie haben es geschafft, aber
ihnen geht es jetzt schlechter. Da sagen sich alle, wir wollen aber nicht, dass es uns schlechter
geht, wir machen das nicht nach. Also ich denke, mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen, in der
Art und Weise, wie es manchmal so aktuell propagiert wird, wir müssen halt auf alles
mögliche verzichten, uns muss es schlechter gehen, Hauptsache unterm Strich sehen die
Zahlen besser aus. Ich glaube nicht, dass das im Gesamtkontext das Problem löst. Ja,
so, weiter geht es. Und wie gesagt, fliegen verbietet mir aktuell noch gar keiner. Schwebt
manchen vielleicht vor, aber gucken, was da so rauskommt.
Ja, das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut, genau. Nehm dir einfach eine Knippex-Zange und durchtrenne
alle Netzwerkkabel, du bist auch sicher, kannst damit aber nichts mehr machen.
Ein Abo haben hier in der Creative Cloud Desktop. Ihr kennt ja, die beste Firewall, so ein Seitenschneider.
Und dann findet ihr da Photoshop in Klammern Beta, dann installieren, klicken und dann hat
man zwei Photoshop-Versionen, die normale und die Beta. Übrigens passiert die ganze Generiererei
nicht lokal, sondern in der Cloud. Das heißt, man braucht keinen schnellen Rechner, aber eine
stabile Internetverbindung. Und da sage ich jetzt mal nach einem ganzen Tag Ausprobiererei, auch wenn
das noch lange nicht ausgereift ist, wird das die Arbeit in Photoshop stark verändern, ganz sicher.
Also vielleicht muss ich auch mal meinen Videoschnitt-Kram upgraden. Ich habe ja immer
noch eine Vegas-Version von 2012 oder so. Einfach, weil es funktioniert. Aber wenn man
beispielsweise mit Premiere, also bei meinen Videos ist es jetzt nicht so wild, aber hat ja
eben auch gerade einer im Chat das Beispiel gebracht, wenn man jetzt ein Interview hat über
Discord oder Teams oder Zoom oder was auch immer. Man hat quasi Audio- und Video-Feed von
den Leuten und sagt dann über die AI, schleide das Video so, dass immer derjenige zu sehen ist,
der gerade spricht. Das ist natürlich schon richtig große Arbeitserleichterung. Vor allem,
wenn das halt auch was taugt. Für meine Videos jetzt nicht so wirklich relevant.
Alleine ich als Gelegenheitsnutzer hatte schon mehrfach das Problem, dass ich ein Bild in einem
bestimmten Seitenverhältnis brauchte, z.B. für YouTube-Thumbnails oder so. Das Motiv ließ sich
aber nicht so einfach skalieren. Ich hätte gerne oben oder an der Seite was dran geklebt. Ja,
und das geht jetzt. Hier mal so ein Extrembeispiel. Das ist ein Hochformat-Foto von meinem
3003-Kollegen Shahin, wie er im Park steht und mit einem Roboter rumfummelt. Ich hätte das aber
gerne als 16 zu 9 Querformat. Also einfach das richtige Format angelegt, das vorhandene Bild
rein, die weißen Flächen markieren und auf Generieren. Ja, und da baut Photoshop dann
einfach den ganzen Park drum rum. Da oben ist noch ein bisschen weiß, zack und jetzt nicht
mehr. Und das ist wirklich so einfach, wie es aussieht. Sobald ihr irgendwo einen Rahmen
aufzieht, poppt da dieser Balken mit dem Generieren-Knopf auf. Ja, und wenn man da
drauf drückt, kann man da einfach reinschreiben, was man da haben will. Übrigens gab es schon
was dazu gesagt, dass Tim Cook Apple verlässt. Ich habe gar nicht mitbekommen, dass Tim Cook
Apple verlässt. Warum verlässt er Apple? Weil er zu alt ist und in Rente geht oder?
Also, das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt. 20 Jahre, die Siedler. Das könnten wir echt gucken,
das Video. Poste mal, please, den Link. Ist das ein Gamestar-Video von Maurice? Der macht ja wenig
Videos in letzter Zeit, der ist ja eher am streamen. Auch, weil ich die Videos von ihm immer
ganz gerne geguckt habe. Aber das wäre so der richtige Typ dafür, was über Siedler zu erzählen.
Man fragt sich, wie sich die Leute bei TeamSpeak seit den letzten Jahren fühlen. Also, ich glaube,
es gibt da zwei Fraktionen. Es gibt die einen, die schwören einfach immer noch auf TeamSpeak,
weil sie es immer schon benutzt haben und TeamSpeak beste und TeamSpeak vor allem auch
selbst hostbar ist und sowas. Also, TeamSpeak hat, finde ich, schon noch seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es die, die schon längst bei Discord sind.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich die 1000 Kanalpunkte fürs Trinken einsende? Nichts. Doch,
du erinnerst mich dran, dass ich was trinken muss. Hast du recht? Muss ich machen.
Regel ich mir immer so einen trockenen Hals. Du warst nett und hast mich daran erinnert,
dass ich was trinken muss, weil ich jetzt auch gerade gemacht habe. Mehr hast du da nicht von.
Videos Golem. Ein Video bei Golem über die Siedler. Bei Golem? Aber was ist mit denen los?
Seit wann macht Golem denn irgendwelche Videos? Ja, das stimmt. Discord, gerade wenn du auf
Discord-Servern bist, die nicht so viele User haben und dementsprechend noch nicht hochgestuft
wurden, ist die Sprachqualität kacke. Im direkten Call finde ich die ganz okay und Discord hat
eine höhere Verzögerung als TeamSpeak, je nach Codec. Also TeamSpeak hat schon seine
Daseinsberechtigung. Finde, muss man ja auch der Sache zugestehen. Ob TeamSpeak 5 oder was
jetzt rauskommen soll, sich mal irgendwie durchsetzt, ich weiß ja nicht. Ja, ich habe
schon was getrunken. Ich meine, du kannst natürlich deine ganzen Channel-Points raushauen,
wenn du willst, aber mehr als einmal hat eigentlich keinen Sinn. Also TeamSpeak 5 weiß ich gar
nicht, ob das mittlerweile sogar schon offiziell raus ist. Das ist ja quasi so ein Discord
in dem TeamSpeak-Style. TeamSpeak 4 gibt es nicht, es gibt TeamSpeak 2, 3 und 5. So, lass
mal weitergucken. Das ist natürlich schon geil. Nächstes Mal mit
Freistellen und Hintergründen. Du brauchst keinen Photoshop-Typ mehr von Fiverr, der das macht.
Auf der anderen Seite, sobald du halt was Spezifisches haben willst, wenn du schon eine
genauere Vorstellung im Kopf hast. Also ich denke nicht, dass das wirklich Designer ersetzen kann,
denen du sagst, ich habe so und so eine Idee, kannst du mal was cooles bauen? Das wird es in
nächster Zeit wahrscheinlich auch nicht sein, aber für solche schnellen Korrekturen ist das
enorme Zeitersparnis und praktisch. Das Bild ist fake, die Umgebung gibt es nicht. Ja gut,
man sieht es ein bisschen hier, falls es die Umgebung gibt, ein bisschen dahinten. Was soll
das hier sein? Dieser Weg dahinten, macht ja nicht wirklich Sinn, oder? Da gibt es einen Weg
und irgendwie so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen Beton an der Stelle, was hier überhaupt nicht
dahin passt. Oder teilweise schwebende Äste. Und das ist wirklich so einfach, wie es aussieht. Sobald
ihr irgendwo einen Rahmen aufzieht, poppt da dieser Balken mit dem Generieren Knopf auf. Ja,
und wenn man da drauf drückt, kann man da einfach reinschreiben, was man da haben will. Übrigens
gab es schon länger eine Funktion zum inhaltsbasierten Füllen, so hieß die. Die arbeitet
aber lokal und auch nur mit den Daten, die schon im Bild vorhanden sind. Und ja, die ist eine ganze
Ecke schlechter. So sieht die alte Funktion mit diesem Bild im Vergleich aus. Kecke. Schnell
zurück zum KI generierten Park mit Shahin. Und bislang ist das Bild ein bisschen langweilig,
mache ich da doch rechts einfach mal einen Tiger hin. Einfach Auswahlrechtecke aufziehen, Tiger
reinschreiben und dann ist da ein Tiger. Das sieht halt schon enorm fake aus. Man hat immer
drei Varianten, wo man dann so durchschalten kann und die aussucht, die einem am besten gefällt.
Warum fährt da eigentlich kein Affe auf dem Einrad lang? Jetzt schon. Und dann sieht halt
schon enorm fake aus, aber auch nicht schlechter, als irgendwie den Photoshop in der über Pfeiffer
20 Euro bezahlen. Nee, das kenne ich nicht, Tommy. Keine Ahnung. Aber Dankeschön für den
Sub. Sagt mir nichts. Ich habe den Namen schon mal irgendwo gehört, aber ich habe jetzt keine,
also nichts, nichts bei mir im Kopf, was mir gerade sagt, was das ist und wofür man es verwendet.
Passt auch eigentlich ganz gut in den Kühlschrank hin. Ja, ich finde auch,
Shahin sollte einen Ballon in der Hand haben oder vielleicht Akkubohrer. Ja,
und die Klamotten sind auch noch optimierbar. Da noch irgendeine Matte auf den Asphalt.
Es hat nichts auf dem Originalbild übrig. Ja, und da hinten passt auch schön ein UFO hin. Jetzt
fehlt nur noch der Eiffelturm und fertig ist das wunderschöne Bild. Das ist doch viel besser als
die olle Realität. Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt, das sieht aber jetzt auch nicht unbedingt realistisch
aus. Ja, einiges sah da schon nicht realistisch aus. Vor allem Sachen mit Menschen kann die Adobe
KI noch gar nicht gut. Hier guck mal, hier wollte ich mir mal perfekte Szene machen lassen. Ja,
okay, ich sag mal, ganz perfekt ist das noch nicht. Und guck mal hier, mittelalte Frau,
Straßenfotografie, leuchtende Farben. Gebe ich mal hier in Photoshop ein. Ja gut,
auch gar nicht mal. Zum Vergleich, das macht mit Journey in der aktuellen 5.1 Version aus
dem gleichen Prompt und auch der auf lokale Hardware lauffähige Bildgenerierer Stable
Diffusion bekommt das mit dem aktuellen XL Modell besser hin als Firefly in Photoshop.
Aber die Erfahrung zeigt, je länger die Bildgenerierer feintrainiert werden,
desto besser die Ergebnisse. Und wenn Geld dahinter steckt und bei Adobe steckt Geld
dahinter, das ist ja auch immer ein nicht zu unterschätzender Faktor.
Firefly ist so ungefähr auf dem Stand von Stable Diffusion von vor ein paar Monaten. Ich bin da
einigermaßen zuversichtlich, dass das noch besser wird. Anders als Stable Diffusion ist die Adobe
KI ziemlich rigoros, was verbotene Begriffe angeht. Man kann zum Beispiel keine real
existierenden Personen einbauen, nicht mal wenn die schon lange tot sind, wie Einstein zum Beispiel.
Außerdem ging bei meinen Tests nicht Kondom, Pistole, Waffe, Messer, Bootmesser geht aber.
Texte in Bildern würde Adobe wahrscheinlich gerne können, aber das klappt mit der Technik noch nicht
so. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel schreibe, mach da mal ein Schild hin, wo CT 3003 draufsteht. Ja,
das ist aber ein bisschen an allen Bildgenerierern so. Das sieht dann immer ein bisschen aus wie
Aurebesch, diese Schriftsprache im Star Wars Universum. Was man aber machen kann,
die einzelnen Buchstaben vom Bildgenerierer füllen lassen, zum Beispiel mit Neonröhren,
Honig oder Blumen. Ja, aber trotz der ganzen Kritik, die Technik ist trotzdem ein Game Changer. Vor
allem, weil das hier in Photoshop so leicht zu bedienen ist und dass man hier nicht einfach nur
komplette Bilder generiert, sondern Twitchy Modes autogenerate Bildteile. Das ist in der
Praxis wirklich super nützlich. Allein, dass man einfach Objekte, die man nicht haben will,
löschen kann, indem man einfach ein Auswahlrechteck drumherum zieht und auf Generieren drückt,
ohne was einzugeben. Das ist nochmal ein Selfie von mir aus Paris. Mich stört mein Kopf da vorne,
ich will ihn weg haben. Zack, ist er weg. Und das sieht jetzt beim ersten drüber gehen noch
ziemlich schrottig aus, aber ich ziehe einfach immer wieder Rechtecke über die Bildteile,
die mir nicht gefallen. Und ja, am Ende ist ein Bild ganz ohne Kino und zumindest beim
schnellen drauf gucken. Also das ist schon nicht ohne. Hat zwar mit der Realität an der Stelle
nichts mehr zu tun, würde mir jetzt nicht auffallen, dass da was falsch ist. Oder was meint ihr? Ich habe
mal den CT Photoshop Experten André gefragt, der ist gerade in Marrakesch im Urlaub, ob er denkt,
dass wir jetzt von Fake Bildern überschwemmt werden. Moment, wir werden schon von Fake Bildern
überschwemmt überall. Nicht nur von Fake Bildern, sondern auch von Fake Comments. Aber ich jetzt
auch bestimmt in letzter Zeit auch schon in Foren und auch auf Reddit und sowas vermehrt so
Zusammenhänge oder YouTube Comments. YouTube Comments ist auch ein gutes Beispiel. Vermehrt
so zusammenhanglose Kommentare. Auch GitHub, überall. Es ist überall so zusammenhanglose
Kommentare aufgefallen, die irgendwie Bezug zum Inhalt haben, aber nicht passen. Also lasst uns
mal ein Beispiel überlegen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn es ein Video gibt, wie male ich in Photoshop
am besten Bananen? Dann ist so ein typisches KI-Comment, ich finde Birnen schmecken mir aber
viel besser als Bananen. Sowas in der Richtung. Da denkst du immer so, hä? Das hat mit dem Video
doch überhaupt nichts zu tun. Also ein bisschen von Bananen und so, aber mit dem Inhalt nicht.
Du siehst so an jeder Ecke, an allen Ecken siehst du solche. Also dieses Gespamme von Chat-Kommentaren
gibt es leider viel zu viel schon mittlerweile. Und Bilder auch. Also ja, ich glaube, es gibt
übrigens auch viele Foren mittlerweile. Beispielsweise in der Home Assistant Community
ist es mittlerweile verboten, AI-generierte Antworten zu posten, was die Leute nicht
zwangsläufig da immer von abhält, das zu machen. Kennt ihr eine gute Seite, um diese
ganzen KI-Tools aufzulisten? Nee. Google? Nee, aber was immer ganz gut ist, GitHub,
Awesome, AI gibt es garantiert schon. Aber die ist zu alt. Du musst mal nach solchen Listen suchen
auf GitHub. Da gibt es jede Menge zu allen möglichen Themen. Die hier sieht ja auch schon
mal ganz gut aus. Du suchst nach GitHub, Awesome List und dann nach dem Thema, was du willst. In
dem Fall das GitHub, Awesome, AI. Da gibt es ganz viele solcher Listen von Usern erstellt,
wo sie halt so eine eigene Übersicht gebaut haben. Du siehst ja auch, das Ding hat 911 Sterne,
scheint ja auch recht beliebt zu sein. Diskussion, die immer wieder geführt wird,
seit ich das erste Mal mit dem Thema zu tun hatte. Also im Prinzip seit Photoshop 1.0 wird gesagt,
ab jetzt ist Bilder fälschen so einfach, dass man vor Bildfälschung sich nicht mehr retten kann.
Und das ist noch nie passiert. Also es gibt natürlich immer wieder beeindruckende Fälschungen.
Da gibt es Bilder, die sind echt, wo man denkt, das sieht so fake aus. Ja, die Mondlandung zum
Beispiel. Ich denke mal, also das ist ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel. Das wird immer schwieriger,
Fälschung zu erkennen. Aber da muss man eben immer genauer hingucken. Und Medien darf man
spätestens seit Social Media das ganze News-Geschäft übernommen haben und das nicht mehr bei Instanzen
wie Tagesschau und so. Das kann man eh nicht mehr trauen. Also man muss schon sehr genau
hingucken und künftig vielleicht noch genauer. Der SMS wird nicht gerade in Marrakesch. Das
Gebäude im Hintergrund ist kein Fake. Auch in der Videobearbeitung setzt Adobe jetzt KI ein.
Dabei muss KI nicht immer zwingend generativ sein. Habt ihr das bei Discord mitbekommen?
Discord hatte AI-generierte Captures. Falls ihr noch nicht wusstet, was ein Yoko ist. Ein Yoko
ist laut Discord sowas hier. Und da sollte man dann Bilder auswählen. Auf welchem Bild genau
hier. Auf welchem Bild befindet sich ein Yoko? Das dumme ist nur, es weiß halt keiner,
was ein Yoko ist. Yoko sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Auge und ein Jojo oder so. Also Chat,
auf welchen Bildern ist ein Yoko zu sehen? Das vielleicht? Das, das? Man weiß es nicht.
Ich meine, AI-generierte Captures sind ja auch schon ein bisschen weird. Wenn man sich nämlich
mal überlegt, dass Captures ursprünglich dafür erfunden wurden, um Bots, nennen wir es mal AI,
quasi davon abzuhalten, den Service zu benutzen. Also Captures wurden ja dafür erfunden, um zu
checken, ob da ein Mensch davor sitzt, der den Service benutzen will, um Bots auszusperren. Und
jetzt benutzt man quasi AI, um Captures zu generieren, um Bots und AI auszusperren.
Hä? Wahrscheinlich kann AI AI-generierte Captures sogar besser lösen.
Ja, das mit den Ampeln und dem Hydrant ist ja auch so ein Ding. So, bitte wähle alle Busse aus.
Oder, oder was hatte ich, was hatte ich letztens? Bitte wähle alle Geschäfts-, was heißt ein
Storefront? Was heißt das auf Deutsch? Geschäfts-, Ladenfront, ja. Wähle alle Storefronts aus. Und
da hast du dann halt Häuser gesehen und ich dachte mir so, Alter, was weiß ich, ob das ein Shop ist
oder nicht? Und ich hab's dann auch prompt falsch gemacht. Oder wähle, wähle alle Teile von einem
Bus aus, ja, und dann weißt du nicht, so zählt dieser Pixel jetzt noch dabei oder nicht? Ja,
Hydranten, Ampeln, also die Klassiker. Also was Neues erschaffen und da ist Premiere ein gutes
Beispiel, wie KI Dinge einfacher machen kann. Guck mal hier, das ist eine Aufnahme von einem
älteren 3003 Video. Habt ihr vielleicht schon gesehen, da spreche ich über die gefährlichste
Malware der PC-Geschichte. Normalerweise würde man jetzt im Schnitt eben über einen Cut setzen,
wo ich mich verspreche oder einen Satz zweimal sage und das dann so zurecht trimmen. Dieser
Schritt dauert aber und ist ja auch eher langweilig. Mit dem textbasierten bearbeitenden
Premiere kann ich mir jetzt einfach ein Transkript erstellen lassen und dann anhand von dem Text
einfach Stellen herausschneiden. Okay, das ist wirklich nice. Das ist wirklich nice. Das
kann ich, das erspart sicherlich einiges an Arbeit. Im Prinzip transkribiert die Software alles,
was im Video gesagt wird und kann dabei auch zwischen unterschiedlichen Sprecherinnen und
Sprechern unterscheiden. Das Transkribieren allein ist jetzt noch nicht so besonders,
gibt es ja schon länger. In den letzten Monaten ist zum Beispiel Whisper von OpenAI auch bedeutend
besser geworden. Was aber wirklich neu ist, ist die Möglichkeit jetzt einfach hier zu klicken
und einen Teil des Videos über dieses Textfeld zu entfernen. Das ist cool. Einfach Command und
X klicken. Ich habe ja keinen Bock Premiere zu lernen, aber das ist schon cool. Und schon wird
die entsprechende Stelle aus dem Video geschnitten. Richtig praktisch ist das auch, wenn ihr jetzt zum
Beispiel einen bestimmten Teil aus dem Clip kopieren möchtet, wenn ihr nur einen bestimmten
Teil des Videos braucht. Dann klickt ihr einfach hier auf Suche und gebt das Schlagwort ein und
wählt den Textausschnitt aus und habt dann genau den Teil, den ihr braucht, ausgeschnitten. Das
alles funktioniert lokal auf dem Rechner. In unseren Tests auf einem MacBook Pro mit M2 Max
ging das alles super schnell. Klar, mit älterer Hardware ist das ein bisschen mühseliger. Ich
hoffe mal, dass ich mit meinem 13900K und der 4090 RTX ganz gut aufgestellt bin für sowas.
Das ist mit Videoschnitt ja immer so eine Sache. Das Ganze funktioniert jetzt schon relativ gut,
aber wenn sich das Audio jetzt auch noch automatisch ein- und ausblenden will,
also die Übergänge zwischen den Schnitten nicht mehr hörbar wären, dann könnte man nur über den
Texteditor den Rohschnitt von so einem Talking-Head-Video machen und uns würde das wirklich
viel Zeit sparen. Und ich glaube, ich lehne mich jetzt nicht allzu weit aus dem Fenster, wenn ich
sage, dass Adobe diese Funktionen und auch wahrscheinlich noch ganz viele andere KI-Tools
integrieren wird. Es gibt ja jetzt schon die Möglichkeit, die eigene Stimme digital zu klonen.
Stell dir mal vor, was damit dann möglich sein könnte. Rein hypothetisch könnte man dann in
Premiere einfach einen Text eingeben und die Person, die da im Bild ist, sagt den dann. Die
entsprechende Mundbewegung zu simulieren, das ist ja jetzt auch schon möglich mit KI. Dann könnte
man nicht nur den Text auswählen, den man ausschneiden möchte oder rauskopieren, sondern
eben auch neuen Text eingeben, der dann im Video drin ist. Wenn ich dann in so einem 3003-Video
an der Stelle noch einen Satz hinzufügen möchte, wäre das einfach in Premiere möglich. Jetzt im
Moment ist das quasi unmöglich, weil ich den Take ja komplett neu drehen müsste und einige Details
im Bild niemals wieder so hinkriege, wie beim ersten Dreh. Also zum Beispiel, wie meine Haare
aussehen. Okay, zugegeben, das ist alles noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik. Wir wollen uns ja
anschauen, was jetzt schon geht und da hat Adobe in Premiere noch eine KI-Funktion, die wirklich
super hilfreich sein kann. Denn auch ein anderes KI-Feature in Premiere Pro hilft uns beim Schneiden
der 3003-Videos. Wir verwenden im Hintergrund ja oft Musik und die laden wir uns von der Plattform
runter und suchen eben entsprechend nach Stimmung und so aus. Das Problem ist, die Musik ist nie
genau so lang, wie wir die im Hintergrund bräuchten und da hilft die Remix-Funktion unter
Essential Sound. Damit ist es nämlich möglich, genau einzustellen, wie lang ein Musikstück sein
soll und die KI zieht die Musik dann nicht einfach kürzer oder länger, sondern erstellt quasi einen
Remix, der beliebig lang sein kann. In den allermeisten Fällen funktioniert das Ganze
mittlerweile so sauber, dass man die Übergänge gar nicht mehr hört. Damit kann quasi mit ein paar
Klicks aus dem 2-Minuten-Track ein 15-Minuten-Track werden. Und das zeigt, finde ich ganz deutlich, KI.
Für so Hintergrund-Gedudel ist das sehr sehr praktisch.
Bei euch geht eben deutlich über das reine Erstellen von Content mittels Prompts und
Tools wie ChatGPT mit Journey, Stability Fusion oder eben Adobe Firefly hinaus. Da gibt es mittlerweile
so viele Kleinigkeiten, die das Arbeiten deutlich leichter und schneller machen. Es fängt beim
automatischen Freistellen in Photoshop an und geht bis zum automatischen Farbabgleich in Premiere,
und das ersetzt alles jetzt nicht die kreative Eigenleistung, aber macht den Weg dahin schneller
und komfortabler. Bevor das hier jetzt zur kompletten Lobhudelei für Adobe endet,
ich muss zumindest mal sagen, dass ich das unschön finde, dass man Adobe Software nicht
mehr kaufen kann, sondern für teures Geld abonnieren muss.
Naja gut, ja, das ist ja ein Trend, den es bei vielen Dingern leider gibt mittlerweile.
Und ein Trend, der auch total aus dem Ruder läuft mittlerweile, wenn man sich mal überlegt,
Adobe findet das klasse. Wenn man sich mal überlegt, man kann sich mittlerweile Kameras
kaufen, also Überwachungskameras, und die kann man nur gescheit mit einem Abo benutzen. Also
man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Man kauft sich eine Hardware, baut die
sich hin, packt die bei sich lokal ins WLAN und kann sie nicht richtig verwenden ohne Abo. Oder
zumindest die interessantesten Funktionen nicht verwenden ohne Abo. Das ist so hängen geblieben
mittlerweile.
Job und Premiere kosten einzeln je 23,79 Euro im Monat. Die ganze Creative Suite mit 20 Programmen
kostet 61,95 Euro. Das sind im Jahr fast 750 Euro. Dennoch, mit den KI-Funktionen bekommt man
zumindest jetzt eine ganze Menge mehr fürs Geld. Tschüss.
Schon preislich, nicht ohne.
Zahlt der Arbeitgeber? Naja, ich glaube bei mir nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der Arbeitgeber mir einen Adobe Creative Cloud Abo bezahlt.
Ich wüsste nicht, wo ich das als Linux System, als Linux Engineer,
wie heißt mein Job genau? Keine Ahnung, als Linux Admin quasi brauchen sollte.
Ein Adobe Creative Suite Abo.
Für Dokumentation? Ja, da brauche ich ein Chat-GPT Premium Abo.
Ich habe übrigens letztens was gefunden für mein Auto. Und zwar,
also ich werde das nicht einbauen, ja ich sage nur. Also ich habe ja einen Fiat 500e und ich
habe ein Auto gekauft, was mal als Vorführauto benutzt wurde. Es war dann halt im Endeffekt
günstiger, hatte nicht so viele Kilometer drauf und es gab halt direkt, gab es es ohne irgendwie
ein halbes Jahr, ein Jahr warten zu müssen. So und das Einzige, was mich halt ein bisschen
daran stört ist, dass ich keine gescheite Rückfahrkamera habe. Normalerweise hat der
500e eine Rückfahrkamera, aber meine hat keine Rückfahrkamera. Ich habe nur so Rückfahrsensoren,
die piepen ja, wo du dann siehst. So, was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ist, ich habe halt vom alten
Auto noch die Kamera dran gepappt. Ich hatte ja im alten Auto auch eine Kamera zum Rückwärtsfahren,
aber es wäre halt cool, wenn man das eingebauten Display verwenden könnte. So und ich habe letztens
was gefunden. Es gibt wohl irgendwie, es gibt wohl irgendwie ein Nachrüstkameraset für den Fiat.
Warum ist mein Browser wieder kaputt? Keine Ahnung. Für den Fiat 500e.
Und das ist, ich finde es, ich finde es jetzt nicht. Also für den neuen 500e. Und das ist sehr,
sehr weird champ beschrieben, wie das eingebaut wird. Da musst du irgendwie die Abdeckung aufmachen,
dann hoffen, dass du die richtigen Anschlüsse hast. Also das ist mir viel zu vage. Im Zweifelsfall
mache ich da die Elektronik in meinem Auto kaputt, wenn ich da irgendeinen Mist anbaue,
ohne dass ich weiß, was ich mache. Deswegen, ich hoffe drauf, dass vielleicht irgendwie
meine Werkstatt bei mir in der Nähe so die nächsten 1-2 Jahre das anbietet.
Dass ich eine Rückfahrkamera nachrüsten kann, die über das eingebaute Display geht.
Das wäre schon sehr nice.
Bei euch haben Leute Adobe Cloud nutzen sie nicht. Tja,
weiß ich nicht, ob es das bei uns gibt, aber ich glaube, ich kriege als Linux
IT Mensch bei uns kein Adobe Creative Suite Abo.
Ja, das geht, aber das will ich ja nicht. Ich will ja das Onboard System weiterverwenden.
Und die haben ja auch einen Monitor vorne integriert und da will ich halt die Kamera drauf anzeigen.
Wie soll Kubernetes ohne Adobe Cloud? Interessante Frage. Vielleicht soll ich das mal erzählen und
ich habe Glück, dass die Leute, denen ich das erzählen muss, keine Ahnung haben, was Kubernetes
ist und sagen, ja, okay, wenn sie das für Kubernetes brauchen, dann gibt es auch ein
Adobe Creative Suite Abo. Ich meine, bei Kubernetes Konfiguration muss man auch kreativ sein oftmals.
Vielleicht rechtfertigt das ja die Creative Suite.
Na ja, so Leute, jetzt, wo so viele von euch da sind, jetzt nochmal die Frage. Ich habe es am
Anfang schon gefragt, da waren aber kaum noch Leute da. Oder waren kaum schon Leute da. Frage an euch.
Habt ihr schon Ergebnisse von eurer IHK Abschlussprüfung, wie sie oder Fachinformatiker
Anwendungsentwicklung oder wie heißen die anderen Fachinformatiker strukturierte Vernetzung oder
sowas? Data Science, ach, Big Data, Physik. Also habt ihr schon die Ergebnisse von eurer
Fachinformatiker Prüfung und wie sind die ausgefallen? Ich weiß, dass einige von euch
geschrieben haben. Ob jetzt natürlich Leute, die jetzt da sind, geschrieben haben, das weiß ich
nicht. Aber ich habe gehört, dass die vorläufigen Ergebnisse da sind. Da würde mich mal interessieren,
wie das bei euch so ausgefallen ist. Hat vielleicht, lasst uns gerade mal gucken,
hat vielleicht Technik Keller ein Video dazu gemacht, wie seine Abschlussprüfung gelaufen ist?
Ah, ich dachte schon, was soll ich tun? Ich bin durchgefallen oder sowas kommt jetzt. Ich will
es ja wirklich nicht hoffen. Ich drücke ihm die Daumen, dass er das schafft oder bestanden hat.
Noch nicht. Okay, also keiner da, der eine Abschlussprüfung Ergebnisse hat. Oder die
Ergebnisse sind so schlecht, dass die Leute sich nicht outen wollen. Das kann natürlich
auch sein. Was haben wir denn hier? Können wir uns denn noch mal reinziehen?
Googles Zip-Domain are worse than I thought. Ja, wir haben schon ein Video von ihm geguckt.
Und da hat er was über die Zip-Domains erzählt und hatte auch ein paar Punkte,
an die habe ich gar nicht gedacht. Mal gucken, ob es da was Neues zu gibt. Ist ja auch drei Tage
alt. Das ist auf jeden Fall, genau, das haben wir das letzte Video. Mal gucken, was es da,
ob es da irgendwas Neues gibt, was ich noch nicht mitbekommen habe. Also für alle, für alle,
die es nicht mitbekommen haben, sage ich das jetzt noch mal. Es gibt eine neue Domain,
eine neue Top-Level-Domain, nämlich Punkt Zip. Das hat Google wohl mit initiiert,
dass es das gibt. Und das Blöde an einer Domain Punkt Zip in dem Fall ist halt,
genauso wie es bei Punkt Echse wäre, dass Zip, zumindest was Windows angeht,
ja ein recht beliebtes Dateiformat ist und dementsprechend das Raum für Scams gibt.
Zum Beispiel einer der ersten Domains, die registriert wurde von Punkt Zip war Microsoft
Office. Geht da nicht drauf, ja. Punkt Zip. So und jetzt überlegt euch mal,
jemand verschickt so eine Mail, hier Microsoft Office zum Runterladen, Microsoft Office Punkt
Zip und du bist irgendein Noob, der die E-Mail öffnet. Die denken dann natürlich,
ach guck mal hier, das ist ja der Anhang von der Mail. Aber nein, das ist kein Anhang mehr,
sondern es ist ein Link auf eine Domain mit einem gültigen Zertifikat auch,
weil demjenigen gehört ja auch die Domain und darauf gibt es dann irgendeine Phishing-Seite,
die versucht dann Microsoft Account abzugreifen. Also man sieht schon,
man kann dann sehr viel, hat hohes Missbrauchspotenzial und dann gibt es noch andere
Sachen, zum Beispiel, dass man sowas hier macht. Ich weiß, es ist nicht ganz korrekt,
aber ich zeige es euch trotzdem mal, dass man hier sowas Punkt macht,
github.com at, keine Ahnung, hier, office.zip, so zum Beispiel. So und was das macht ist folgendes,
das hat nichts mit GitHub zu tun, übrigens dürfen keine normalen Slashes an der Stelle sein,
sondern man braucht irgendwelche Unicodes, Zeichen, die aussehen wie Slashes. So und
was das hier macht ist folgendes, das geht nicht etwa zu GitHub, sondern, wobei ich bin nicht ganz
sicher bin, ob die Syntax stimmt. Könnte sogar sein, dass da noch ein Doppelpunkt rein muss.
Zumindest, was an der Stelle, ne, hier ist noch ein Doppelpunkt, passt doch. Also was es macht ist
folgendes, es geht nicht zu github.com und dort lädt es eine office.zip runter, nein,
es geht zu office.zip und meldet sich mit dem Username, HTTPS als Username und dem hier als
Passwort auf dieser Domain an. Also das ist quasi Basic Auth, das ist die Basic Auth Schreibweise
für Domains. Also die gibt es schon ganz lange. Normalerweise sehen die so aus. Zum Beispiel die
HTTP Doppelslash und dann hier max.123456 at google.de. Das ist so die Basic Auth Schreibweise
für Domains. Und in der Stelle, wenn diese Slashes hier keine Slashes sind, sondern nur
Unicode Zeichen, die aussehen wie Slashes, dann ist für den Browser das hier, das hier der Username
und das hier das Passwort für die Domain office.zip. Also es sieht so aus auf den ersten Blick, als wäre
es github, aber in Wirklichkeit geht es auf office.zip. Also da kann man ganz viele, ganz
eklige Sachen mit treiben und deswegen ist das Beste, was man aus meiner Sicht machen kann und
das habe ich bei mir auch gemacht, office zu blocken, alle Domains. Also ich habe regex bei
mir im dns drin. Ich habe bestimmt gar keinen. Es ist kein regex. Ich habe gesagt, endet mit
.zip, fliegt raus. Der würde ja dann github.com als Username. Der würde als Username folgendes
nehmen. Also das hier wäre der Username und das hier wäre das Passwort. Und wie gesagt,
das geht nur, wenn man keine normalen Slashes nimmt, sondern Unicode Zeichen, die aussehen wie
Slashes. Dem könnte man noch leicht entgegenwirken, zumindest der Browser. Ja, und ich gehe auch davon
aus, dass die Browser das mit den nächsten Versionen machen werden. Also gerade für Zip.
Mal gucken, was er dazu sagt.
Also ich weiß eh nicht, was mit Google, was Google geritten hat, diese Domain anzubieten,
weil ich habe keine Ahnung, warum Google das macht. Das leuchtet mir auch nicht ein. Die Leute bei
Google sind doch nicht doof. Das war denen auch garantiert von Anfang an klar. Also der einzige
Grund, den ich mir mal wieder erklären kann bei Google ist, dass sie sich dazu entschieden haben,
das zu machen, entgegen der bewussten Probleme, die es geben wird, weil sie denken, dass es für
ihre Geschäftszwecke von Vorteil ist. Warum auch immer.
Ja, hier zeigt er es nochmal.
Ja, die müssten das aber filtern, weil ansonsten sind ja Domains mit Unicode Characters ganz
furchtbar toll, weil es gibt ja Emoji Domains mittlerweile. Und was würden wir ohne Emoji
Domains machen?
Ja, das stimmt. Da habe ich ja noch gar nicht dran gedacht. Stimmt, wenn es Mails gibt,
wo Microsoft-Office.zip drin steht, was bisher noch kein gültiger Link war und die Mail wird
neu gerendert, dann ist es jetzt auf einmal ein gültiger Link, weil es eben diese Domain gibt.
Ja, es könnte durchaus Probleme geben, wobei normalerweise. Ja, wobei,
warten wir mal, das muss nicht zwangsläufig so sein. Also ich habe meine Mails prinzipiell
eh nur als Plaintextanzeige. Dayscode, dankeschön für den Sub.
Aber hier ist das Ding, es wird retroaktiviert angepasst. Ich meine, hier ist ein Kommentar auf
YouTube von vor 4 Jahren, der 42.zip erwähnt hat, ein berühmter Zip-Bomb,
welcher effektiv dein gesamtes Harddrive füllt, wenn du es ausfüllst. Und was passiert,
wenn du auf 42.zip den Domain gehst, den du nicht automatisch ausfüllen sollst?
...downloads that Zip-Bomb-File. Or at least it depends on your browser. Like,
on Microsoft Edge, it will download...
...macht Twitch bei allem. Ja, ja, das ist ja schön und gut. Also,
das ist, das ist ja okay, aber die Domain gibt es nicht. Bei .zip gibt es die Domain. Das hier
kann ich anklicken, da gibt's nix. Jetzt stell dir mal vor, jemand würde die Domain,
die Top-Level-Domain .pommes rausgeben. Dann könnte das auf einmal ein gültiger Link sein,
wo irgendein Download startet. Das ist ja das eigentliche Problem.
Also ich hab, ich hab Zip-Domains einfach komplett geblockt.
...probably imagine how bad this could get. I mean, imagine all the people that have ever
written an email and mentioned that they attached attachment.zip to it. Or anyone
that does that going forward without realizing it's domain. Well, anyone who clicks that link
is now gonna get rickrolled, because that's what that domain directs to. That's just a silly...
Wenigstens einer, der mal sinnvoll die ganze Sache hier registriert hat. Und was Sinnvolles mit
gemacht hat.
...will convert domains to links for both incoming and outgoing messages. But at the moment does not
do so for .zip domains. So we'll have to see if that stays the case. Outlook did not seem
to convert any links when I tested it. But Apple Mail did. Though still not .zip domains.
But plenty of other websites also do the same thing and convert links. Such as Twitter, LinkedIn,
Facebook apparently, sometimes like in comments. Reddit does it. But it's not just for social
Das mit der Zip-Domain ist ein typischer Fall, wo man, also muss ich alles sagen, das ist ja so eine alles-oder-nichts-Argumentation, ja?
Also, nur weil irgendjemand max.ist.doof als irgendwo reingeschrieben hat, darf man das nicht mehr .doof als Top-Level-Domain registrieren.
Ich glaube, damit kommt man in dem Fall nicht weiter, denn gerade bei Zip dürfte es ja offensichtlich sein, dass das anscheinend immer so ist.
Und auf die Idee hätte man vorher kommen können, ja? Dass jetzt keiner, dass ich eine Datei auch blablabla.blablabla nennen kann und das theoretisch irgendwann mal eine gültige Top-Level-Domain sein kann, würde ich jetzt nicht auf die gleiche Ebene .zip-Domain registrieren.
Das war eines der ersten Domains, die registriert wurden. Microsoft-Office.zip
Also das ist wirklich problematisch, gebe ich ihm recht.
Geht es HTML? Fragezeichen. Ja, HTML geht immer. Weiß nicht, was du meinst. Geht es HTML?
Geht es HTML? Fragezeichen. Ja, HTML geht immer. Weiß nicht, was du meinst.
Ach geht es um HTML nicht direkt?
Ja, das frage ich mich tatsächlich.
Ja, das würde mich tatsächlich interessieren, warum sie das durchgeworfen haben.
Hä?
Was hat das jetzt genau mit dem eigentlichen Problem zu tun?
Und außerdem. Und außerdem. Hey, guck mal. Ja? Also ich finde das funktioniert in dem Fall schon mal gar nicht. Ja, .com wurde unter Windows für ausführbare Dateien benutzt. Es gibt eine Domain mit .com. Es wurden wenige .com-Dateien verschickt, aber jetzt nur mal so.
Man könnte ja auch sagen, das war eh schon eine blöde Idee damals. Warum sollte man eine blöde Idee nochmal wiederholen, 30 Jahre später und dann mit einer viel verbreiteteren Dateiendung für Windows? Also warum sollte man was Blödes nochmal machen, nur weil man es einmal schon gemacht hat?
Ich sage als nächstes kommt .exe als Domain oder so.
Das sehe ich ehrlich gesagt auch so. Das ist eine bescheuerte Idee gewesen.
Das ist eine bescheuerte Idee gewesen.
Eiken winkt die durch anscheinend. Und die fanden, das ist kein Problem.
Kannst du zeigen, wie du es bei dir geblockt hast? Ich kann euch ein Screenshot von machen. Das wird euch aber wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel bringen, weil ihr wahrscheinlich einen anderen Router habt bzw. einen anderen DNS verwendet als ich.
Ich kann euch ein Screenshot machen, wenn euch das was bringt. Wart mal hier. DNS. Static. Zip.
So sieht das bei mir aus.
So einen Eintrag habe ich bei mir im Router gemacht.
Also alles was mit .zip endet, wird aufgelöst auf Localhost.
Das ist ein statischer Eintrag.
Wie man das bei euch im jeweiligen DNS macht, lokal? Keine Ahnung. Kommt drauf an, was ihr habt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es sogar in der Fritzbox irgendwie geht.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, wie man in der Fritzbox statische DNS-Domains umleitet.
Kannst du die Hostdatei ändern? Das ist dann aber halt doof.
Oder wenn ihr einen PiHole oder einen AdGuard habt, dann ist es relativ einfach.
Die Liste ist lang. Ja, es gibt .gay. Das gibt es übrigens auch. Kein Witz.
Es gibt mittlerweile .gay als Domain.
Und .amazon.
Also es gibt jede Menge Top-Level-Domains. Das wurde vor ein paar Jahren massiv erweitert.
Die Möglichkeiten an Top-Level-Domains.
Du kannst ja mittlerweile auch Emoji-Domains benutzen.
.vermögensberatung
Das ist ja ein ganz griffiger Begriff.
Nicht Emoji-Top-Level-Domain. Ich weiß nicht, ob es...
Emoji-Top-Level-Domain. Es gibt Emoji-Domains.
Die... Genau. Hier. So.
Die funktionieren allerdings nicht wirklich mit Emojis.
Die Emojis werden vorher encoded in irgendeine...
Frag mich nicht, was das ist. Irgendeine Sonderzeichen-Escape-Sequenz.
Und Puni-Code. Ja, doch. Das heißt glaube ich wirklich so.
Und da kann man jetzt Domains aufmachen mit Emojis.
Ich glaube als Top-Level-Domains gibt es das noch.
Wobei...
Doch wahrscheinlich gibt es das mittlerweile auch schon als Top-Level-Domains.
Es gibt so viel... So viel neuen Kram.
Du könntest dir durchaus vorstellen, dass es die ein oder anderen Emojis auch schon als Top-Level-Domains gibt.
Aubergine-Top-Level-Domain. Ja.
Ja gut, warum nicht?
Ist die Smart-Home-Zukunft schon vorbei?
Naja.
Was ist mit meinem Browser los? Warum ist mein Browser kaputt?
Ich glaube ich muss mal kurz meinen Browser...
...meinen Browser neu starten.
Der hat irgendwie einen Geist draufgegeben.
Yes.
Ich weiß nicht, was Chrome gerade für Schmerzen hat, aber anscheinend geht es jetzt wieder.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch, was wir mal gucken könnten?
Air-Tag im Koffer, ist das erlaubt? Ja, das habe ich ja schon gerade aufgeklärt.
Ja, Air-Tags im Koffer sind erlaubt.
Elektrotechniker werden.
Mein Job ist das.
Mein Job in der Autobahn.
Warum habe ich das nur offen? Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Ne, ich glaube wir haben das nur bis zur Hälfte geguckt.
Smarter Hasenstall.
Ich glaube das haben wir noch gar nicht geguckt.
Das finde ich immer sehr spannend, was die Leute da...
...bauen.
Die ganzen Tabs.
Irgendwo muss es hin.
Es wird noch schlimmer.
Der Auer.
Kann man verhindern, dass das eigene Smartphone von anderen Air-Tags benutzt wird?
Weiß es nicht.
Ist das Apple?
Ja, das ist Apple.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es nicht geht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich weiß es aber nicht, ob das...
Keine Ahnung.
Dann ist mal...
Ja gut, das ist aber auch fair, dass man sagt,
dann darf man es selbst nicht benutzen,
wenn man es ausschaltet.
Und das basiert das System ja drauf, dass viele iPhones weltweit unterwegs sind.
Wenn die Leute das alle ausschalten,
dann klappt's halt nicht.
Also insofern versteh ich's, macht schon Sinn.
Was ich, wo ich nicht mitmache, ist bei Unity Media damals noch.
Die hatten ja diese Geschichte mit Unity Media Hotspots so.
Man hat seinen eigenen Router als Hotspot zur Verfügung gestellt,
für andere Leute, dass sie darüber surfen konnten.
Das ging quasi über ein eigenes,
getrenntes, also ein Public WLAN,
was intern über ein eigenes WLAN ging,
sodass es mit dem Netzwerktraffic von einem selbst nichts zu tun hatte.
Da hab ich mich aber auch opt-outet direkt.
Da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Und danach hab ich aber trotzdem gesehen,
die SSID ist irgendwie weiter offen geblieben.
Also bei meinem Unity Media Modem damals.
Und wisst ihr, was ich gemacht hab?
Bei dem Unity Media Modem, ich hab einfach die Antenne abgebrochen.
Und dann war die SSID weg.
Also eigentlich darf man das Ding ja nicht kaputt machen,
weil man's ja wieder zurückgeben muss.
Aber ich dachte mir, die einfachste Variante,
ich will bei dem Ding ja selbst kein WLAN benutzen oder sowas.
Das hab ich ja wirklich rein als Modem verwendet.
Oder halt als Zugangspunkt zum Netz.
Ich hab einfach die Antenne abgebrochen und abgemacht.
Ja, abdrehen ging nicht. Du musstest die abbrechen.
Antenne abgebrochen und seitdem ist die SSID weg.
Mittlerweile hab ich das Ding ja eh nicht mehr.
Keck ALU drüber.
Ich glaub, ALU-Mutter heißt auf Indisch Kartoffeln mit Erbsen.
Ich glaub, ALU ist Kartoffel und Mutter sind Erbsen oder sowas.
ALU-Mutter.
Hab ich mal in irgendeinem indischen Supermarkt in Frankfurt gelernt.
Kann man bestimmt gebrauchen.
Ich glaub, ALU-Mutter heißt auf Indisch Kartoffeln mit Erbsen.
Ich glaub, ALU ist Kartoffel und Mutter sind Erbsen oder sowas.
Kann man bestimmt gebrauchen, wenn man irgendwelche Scammer anrufen.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Haben wir irgendwas zum Gucken noch?
Ja, wir gucken uns an.
Smarter Hasenstall.
Home Automation.
Es kann sein, dass wir den Part schon geguckt haben,
dann müssen wir zum nächsten Part springen,
weil wir haben irgendwie mitten in dem Video aufgehört zu gucken.
Tom macht seinen Hasenkäfig smart und warm.
Das Video haben wir noch nicht ganz gesehen.
Wir haben angefangen, das Video zu gucken
und ich hab's abgebrochen und gesagt, wir gucken's im Stream weiter demnächst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir den Hasenstall schon gesehen haben.
Also wir haben auf jeden Fall die Dunstabzugshaube gesehen.
Aber das Kinderzimmer, die Lüftungsanlagen und so,
das haben wir auf jeden Fall noch nicht gesehen, das weiß ich.
Klopapier-Automation, jetzt geht's los hier.
Eine kleine Automation vor Ort, die dafür sorgt,
dass unsere Hasen im Winter nicht auf Eiswürfel rumkauen müssen.
Das Stall haben wir schon gesehen, okay, next.
Reduzieren.
So, dann haben wir Geralds Kinderzimmer.
Also vielleicht ist es nicht Geralds Kinderzimmer,
weil der wahrscheinlich älter als 1 ist, aber das Zimmer seiner Kinder.
Hallo, ich möchte dir jetzt die Smart Home Automation zeigen,
die ich für das Kinderzimmer unserer kleinen Tochter gebaut habe.
Alles wird dabei über einen Udemy Switch gesteuert.
Die Programmierung dafür wird mit iConnectU und Node-RED realisiert.
Node-RED ist eine coole Sache, ich persönlich mag es allerdings nicht.
Wenn ich Automatisierung programmiere,
dann ist mir irgendeine Programmiersprache lieber.
Node-RED ist ganz cool für Leute, die gerne so visuell programmieren.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie das ausschaut.
Genau, dann hat man hier so eine Oberfläche mit ganz vielen Nodes drinnen
und so kann man sich seine Automatisierung zusammen klicken.
Es gibt Plugins für Home Assistant.
Da kann man sich, ich gucke mal, ob ich euch ein Bild zeigen kann.
Ja, genau, das hier ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel.
Ja, ein bisschen kleinerer Screenshot, ja.
Also man kann irgendeine Home Assistant, also guckt,
der hat irgendeinen Erdbeben-Sensor, Erdbeben-Warnung,
da passt er das raus als TSV
und am Ende schickt er in seinem Home Assistant eine Benachrichtigung,
Achtung, Erdbeben-Warnung und sowas.
Also kann man, wenn einem so normale Programmiersprachen
und Sachen für Automatisieren nicht liegen,
ist Node-RED eine ganz coole Geschichte.
Man kann es auch total automatisieren,
das ist eine ganz coole Geschichte.
Man kann es auch total übertrieben machen
und man kann es auch total übertreiben.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal ihn hier an.
Motion-Sensor und sonstiges.
Und das ist schon der Grund, woran man sieht,
deswegen mag ich normale Programmiersprachen
für komplexere Automatisierungen lieber.
Weil das hier sieht,
man blickt doch keine Sau durch,
aber das hier mit einem If, mit ein paar Ifs,
ist wahrscheinlich deutlich einfacher lesbar
als hier dieses grafische Ding.
Ist Geschmackssache.
Also mir ist irgendein Script lieber als Node-RED.
Aber ich denke, Leute,
die es so mit klassischen Programmiersprachen
nicht so am Hut haben,
für die ist Node-RED nice.
Sehr gut.
Gute Idee.
Ich will nicht sagen,
dass die bei uns auch mal
so eine komplette Badesession
im Kinderzimmer weiter durchgeballert hat.
Aber ja, sie lief bei uns ein paar Mal,
als es nicht notwendig war.
Wärmelampe?
Also ich bin mir relativ sicher,
sowas hatten wir nicht, als ich klein war.
Das soll jetzt kein Boomer-Spruch sein,
so nach dem Motto,
gab es bei mir nicht,
braucht man heute auch nicht.
Ich glaube,
sowas hatten wir nicht.
Sinnige Sache.
Chat, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Also es wäre praktisch gewesen,
hier, als wir das Haus renoviert haben,
sowas zu haben,
weil es gab eine Woche,
da hat sich hier im Haus
alles so ein bisschen überschlagen.
Also es wurde verputzt,
dann kamen die Typen,
die den Boden gemacht haben
und danach kamen auch die Leute,
die die Kacheln an die Wand machen wollten
und sowas.
Und es hat sich alles ein bisschen überschnitten.
Und an einem Tag,
als wir das Haus renoviert haben,
und an einem Tag,
haben wir nichts anderes gemacht,
wie die Wände zu trocknen.
Also überall soweit es ging,
zu heißen,
Heizen,
Heizlüfter reinzustellen
und das ging dann so weit,
dass wir irgendwann mit
mehreren Föhns
und ich mit meiner
Heißluft,
Heißluftgebläse,
also so einem,
wie nennt man das offiziell?
So ein Ding.
Heißluftpistole, ja,
mit so einer Heißluftföhn,
rumgelaufen bin und die Wände getrocknet habe.
Also die Wände im Bad,
dass dann einen Tag später alles so weit trocken war,
dass die Leute die Fliesen legen konnten.
Ja, wir hatten da wirklich alles.
Heizung soweit ging an,
Heizlüfter reingestellt,
also in dem Bad war es irgendwie,
keine Ahnung,
50 Grad oder so,
einfach, dass die Wände getrocknet sind.
Also,
das musste halt sein,
weil sonst,
wenn die Wände da drunter nass sind,
dann haften die Fliesen nicht richtig.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt,
an dem man im Zimmer wieder Licht ein- oder ausschaltet.
Außerdem habe ich einen alten Lautsprecher
mit einem Raspberry Pi Zero VH
und dem HiFiBerry Mini-Amp ausgestattet
und darauf Max2Play installiert.
Okay.
Was ist Max,
Max2Play?
Was ist das?
Ein Linux-based Audio-Video-Player.
Und,
okay, dass er irgendwelche Kinderlieder abspielen kann
im Kinderzimmer oder so wahrscheinlich.
So, das war es auch schon von mir.
Ich hoffe, es war für den einen oder anderen interessant.
Ja, ich glaube, das hilft dem einen oder anderen,
gerade bei frischen Eltern,
die durch Übermüdung
keinen klaren
Ich finde es eine gute Idee.
Gedanken fassen können,
was sie
oder wie sie irgendwas zu Hause automatisieren können,
ist das, glaube ich, eine ganz nette Inspiration
und das Zusammenspiel von den verschiedenen Dingen,
also dass die Wärmelampe
Ja, also die neuen Raspberry Pi Zeros
sind viel zu teuer.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es aussieht,
ob es überhaupt aktuell
noch die normalen Zeros gibt.
Alter!
38 Euro?
40 Euro?
Die haben, glaube ich, mal 6 oder 7 Euro gekostet.
Oder 10 oder sowas.
Die waren, die waren mal,
also die alten Raspberry Pi Zeros waren richtig günstig.
Okay, die Wi-Fi-Dinge haben vielleicht ein paar Euro mehr gekostet.
Ich glaube, die Wi-Fi-Dinge haben 15 oder so gekostet.
Und das ist, das ist ordentlich.
Wir können mal gucken.
Wir können doch mal,
wir können doch mal kurz schauen,
Preisentwicklung.
Preis, Preis, Preis, Preisentwicklung.
Ja, 15 Euro haben die mal gekostet.
Die, die Zero, die Zero-Modelle.
Äh, die, die WLAN, die Zero-Wi-Fi-Modelle.
Und ich glaube, die, die haben ursprünglich
tatsächlich auch mal 6 Euro gekostet,
die, die normalen Zeros.
Also das ist schon krass.
Also Raspberry Pis lohnen sich aktuell gar nicht.
Raspberry Pis, das ist halt,
ich denke, dass diese,
die Knappheit,
ne, den, ich meine nicht den Pico,
ich habe zwar den Pico,
den habe ich aber für noch nicht verwendet.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, wofür ich den benutzen sollte.
Dann nehme ich lieber den ESP32.
Ähm, ich glaube nicht,
dass diese,
diese Knappheit an Raspberry Pis
dem Produkt zugute kommt.
Ich meine, es wird vielleicht dem Hersteller kurzzeitig
zugute kommen, dass sie viel Geld irgendwie machen können.
Weiß ich nicht, aber
auf lange Sicht wird es dem Produkt nicht gut tun.
Denn der riesen Vorteil von einem Raspberry Pi
ist die Kombination aus
Preis,
Tutorials,
Verfügbarkeit,
ähm,
angepasste Pin-Header.
Das, also Raspberry Pi ist einfach das Ökosystem,
was das gut macht.
Es gibt Sachen, die sind schneller,
es gibt Sachen, die sind billiger,
ähm,
leistungsfähiger,
bessere Hardware für spezielle Sachen,
gibt es alles,
aber das Gesamtpaket
und ebenso dieses gesamte Raspberry Pi Ökosystem
ist das, was den Raspberry Pi gut macht.
Und wenn das nicht mehr der Fall ist,
dann
schadet es dem Raspberry Pi einfach,
über, auf lange Sicht.
Deswegen glaube ich nicht,
dass es dem Raspberry Pi langfristig gut tut,
wenn die Dinger einfach unsinnig teuer sind.
Ich suche eine günstige Kiste für Batocera,
Playstation 1,
äh, alles mögliche.
Also kein Raspberry Pi,
die sind viel zu teuer
und sind auch als Gaming-Sache,
irgendeine, irgendeine billige
x86-Sync-Client-Kiste von Ebay
sollte es dafür tun.
Äh, Playstation,
Playstation kann so gut wie alles abspielen.
Ja, alte Mini-PCs,
also Playstation ist ja nichts,
was irgendwie ansatzweise Leistung bräuchte.
Äh, auf nem, auf nem Timer
ist aber auch nochmal ausgeschaltet,
wenn man von vorn heraus geht.
Lüftungsanlagen-Eskalation.
Daniel, haben wir ein smartes Upgrade?
Also von meinen Klimaanlagen,
ich meine, ich habe eine Klimaanlage
mit mehreren Innengeräten,
also ich habe nicht mehrere Klimaanlagen,
aber, oh Leute, hier ist eine Mücke an der Wand,
die muss ich mal kurz gerade entsorgen.
Was macht die hier?
Hat sich aus, ausgemottet.
Also von meiner, von meiner Klimaanlage
habe ich nicht groß automatisiert,
also ich habe, ähm,
so eine, äh,
ESP32, das haben wir sogar hier im Stream mal gemacht,
eine ESP32 mit ner Infrarot-LED
zum Ein- und Ausschalten, die man,
was man dafür benutzen könnte,
was ich eigentlich kaum benutze,
ich benutze die ganz normale Fernbedienung,
meistens,
wofür das ganz praktisch ist,
dass ich feststellen kann,
zum Beispiel, wenn ich mich auf dem Heimweg befinde,
im Zug, und ich komme innerhalb von 20 Minuten an,
dann kann ich sie schon mal einschalten und sowas.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, muss ich sagen,
habe ich wenig automatisiert bei meiner Klimaanlage.
Also die Klimaanlage aktuell ist ja auch nur,
also es ist eine, eine Klimaanlage halt außen,
das ist die eigentliche Klimaanlage,
und, äh, an Geräten innen drinne
habe ich nur in zwei Räumen was.
Ich habe bei mir im Schlafzimmer
so ein Innengerät davon,
die an die Klimaanlage geht,
und ich habe bei mir im Arbeitszimmer,
wo ich jetzt auch sitze,
ja, Streaming, Arbeit, Gaming,
was auch sonst wie immer, Zimmer,
habe ich noch eine Klimaanlage,
also das Innengerät, was zur Klimaanlage geht.
Ich bin jetzt am überlegen,
weil ich glaube, meine Klimaanlage
kann bis zu fünf Innengeräte,
ich bin auch am überlegen,
ob ich Schlafzimmer unten
und Wohnzimmer oben
damit verbinden soll,
verbinden lassen soll.
Das wird ein bisschen, ein bisschen aufwendiger,
da muss man nämlich ein Rohr legen,
und ich muss Handwerker finden, die das machen,
was aktuell echt schwierig ist.
Das sollte sich, denke ich, preislich doch irgendwie
in Grenzen halten,
weil die Klimaanlage ist ja schon da.
Da bin ich ernsthaft am überlegen,
das zu machen,
weil die nächsten Jahre über
wird es wahrscheinlich noch wärmer werden.
Wohnraum-Lüftungssystem bekommen.
Da bin ich sehr interessiert.
Unser Vermieter hat in unseren Wohnungen
in jedem Raum ein aktives Lüftungssystem installiert.
Dabei handelt es sich um einen Durchgangsbogen
in der Außenwand mit einem integrierten Axiallüfter.
Da bin ich sehr hellhörig,
denn sowas haben wir für das neue Haus auch geplant.
Alle Lüfter in der Wohnung können hier
über eine zentrale Steuereinheit
in der Geschwindigkeit und Drehrichtung gesteuert werden.
Das System hat dabei zwei...
Was haben sie da gewickelt?
Was ist denn das hier unten?
Ah, das ist so das Kabel.
Die haben quasi so eine Art...
Ne, das ist kein Netzwerkkabel.
Die haben ganz normales...
Boah, ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Es wird ja immer so nach Durchmesser klassifiziert.
...da gelegt.
...in der Geschwindigkeit und Drehrichtung gesteuert werden.
Das System hat dabei zwei entscheidende Nachteile.
Wenn es draußen...
Ja, genau, Beiss, das meine ich.
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken,
diese Bezeichnung dafür.
...das kalte Luft, teilweise sogar Schnee,
durch den Lüftungsschacht in die Wohnung,
selbst wenn der Lüfter nicht läuft.
Außerdem ist die zentrale Lüftersteuerung
alles andere als smart.
Es kann hier zum Beispiel nicht
in Abhängigkeit der individuellen Raumluftfeuchtigkeit
gelüftet werden.
Es können nur alle Räume gleichzeitig gelüftet werden.
Selbst eine einfache...
Oder es ist Plug-Shit.
...Lüftung ist nicht möglich.
Um diese Nachteile zu beheben,
habe ich eine smarte Version der Lüftungsklappe entwickelt,
die nicht nur dezenter aussieht,
sondern auch noch einige zusätzliche Features mitbringt.
Kannst du mir mehr?
Der mechanische Aufbau beinhaltet
einen Linearentrieb mit einem kleinen...
Alter!
Jetzt will er es aber wissen, oder?
...Motor, durch den sich der Lüftungsschacht...
What the fuck?
Der geht ja richtig ab drauf.
Was hat der denn?
Alter!
Okay, der Typ hat auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Ahnung
von CAD-Anwendungen
und der hat auch schon das eine oder andere Design
in der Richtung.
...schacht elektrisch angetrieben,
Öffnung schließen lässt,
je nachdem, ob der Lüfter aktiv ist oder nicht.
Die Teile wurden so konstruiert,
dass die Herstellung des Systems
per 3D-Drucker möglich ist.
Zur Ansteuerung des Getriebes...
Ey!
Jetzt übertreibt er es aber.
Da wird noch ein eigenes PCB-Design dafür.
...Motors der Endlagerkennung und so weiter,
habe ich eine eigene Elektronik entwickelt.
Über den integrierten Mikrocontroller
kann das Steuersignal...
Alter!
Das kannst du ja schon als Abschlussarbeit.
Moment, hat der so eine eigene...
...so eine eigene Komponentensetzmaschine
oder was hat er da am Start?
Daniel, wir müssen gleich reden.
Machen wir, wenn wir hiermit durch sind.
Die Magic Chinese PCB Assembly Machine...
...die bereits in der Wohnung installiert ist...
Ach nee, das ist zum...
...zentrale Steuereinheit aussendet,
ausgewertet werden.
So wird erkannt, ob der Lüfter läuft
und das Ventil geöffnet werden muss.
Ist klar, ja.
So hat er es da reingeschmissen mit den Tüten
und dann kommt es so raus.
Natürlich!
Sehr schön.
Für den Linearantrieb werden hier
die 3D-gedruckten Bauteile
mit dem kleinen Getriebemotor verschraubt.
Auch die beweglichen Teile
wie die Gewindespindel und das Gegenstück
sind auf einem Low-Cost Creality Ender 3 V2 Drucker
in PLA...
Ja, der ist sehr beliebt.
Der, die, die Ender-Drucker.
...entstanden und das Ganze funktioniert super.
Hier wird noch die...
Es ist wirklich sehr pfeilfett,
was er da gebaut hat.
...Steuerelektronik an den Antrieb montiert
und eine weitere Platine mit den Magnetsensoren
für die Endlagerkennung eingebaut.
Aha, aha, aha.
Obvious, obvious.
Es müssen nun einige Lötverbindungen her...
Also, der hat sowas definitiv schon mal gemacht.
Also, der hat damit schon ein bisschen Erfahrung.
Stichwort, welchen PC würdet ihr als Mindestanforderung
nehmen für Proxmox, TrueNAS, PiHole, NAS, VPN, Git?
Git?
Git hat keine Anforderung auf deinem Server.
Das juckt es nicht.
Plus X.
Tja, also...
Mehrere Kisten oder alles auf einer Kiste?
Also, PiHole braucht keine Leistung großartig.
VPN, naja...
Ja, VPN, je nachdem, wie viel Bandbreite du da drüber hast.
Also, PiHole ist leistungsmäßig zu vernachlässigen.
Und ob du da Git drauf liegen lässt,
das braucht keine Leistung.
Das braucht ein bisschen Storage.
Das ist nicht wild.
Oder du kannst auch GITEA oder sowas drauf installieren.
Das ist Leistungstechnik.
Also, Proxmox, wenn du virtualisieren willst,
ja, braucht ein bisschen Leistung, je nachdem, was du damit machst.
TrueNAS, ja, je nachdem, was du da überträgst.
Und...
VPN, je nachdem, was du an Bandbreite brauchst
und wie viele User das benutzen.
Also, ich würde sagen...
Also, klingt...
Wenn du da mit, sagen wir mal,
Home...
Lab-Performance zufrieden bist,
also, wenn du da jetzt nicht
deine 10 Gigabit...
inklusive Vollverschlüsselung durchbekommen willst...
Oh, danke für den Raid!
Pogu!
Raspberry Pi Cloud!
Wir hatten es gerade von Raspberry Pis,
dass die Dinger eindeutig viel zu teuer sind aktuell.
Danke für den Raid!
Ich bin übrigens...
Muss ich aber jetzt dazu...
Ich bin nicht mal lange da.
Wir wollten uns eigentlich nur noch
das Heimautomatisierungsvideo fertig angucken
und dann war es das wahrscheinlich.
Aber schön, dass ihr da seid.
Pogu, Leute!
Ja, also, zu dieser Thematik nochmal zurückzukommen.
Also, wenn du jetzt nicht da gerade
eine 10 Gigabit-Karte einbauen willst
und das auch vollbekommen willst
mit Vollverschlüsselung und sonst was,
dann reicht dir irgendeine kleine
Low-Power-Intel-Kiste.
Also, was ich zum Beispiel schon...
Was ich verbaut habe,
öfters mal...
Also, öfters...
Klingt jetzt bescheuert,
wo ich mehrere Boards bei mir daheim hatte mal
und so ein bisschen zum Experimentieren
und auch zwei Jahre benutzt habe,
war ein...
War so ein Ding von Astronaut...
Sowas hier in der Richtung ist das.
Es war nicht exakt dieses Board,
aber die Dinger sind ganz gut.
Also, irgendeine Low-Power-Intel-X86-Plattform
reicht da voll und ganz für,
wenn dir Gigabit reicht.
Wenn dir Gigabit reicht,
denn viel mehr kriegst du hier nicht rein.
Die haben zwar auch diese Boards
mit PCI-Express und einem 16-fach-Slot,
die sind dann aber auch nur
zweifach angebunden,
da kriegst du keine 10G voll.
Wenn du mit Gigabit oder 2,5 Gigabit
auskommst,
dann ist diese Plattform tatsächlich,
denke ich, auch immer noch eine Überlegung wert,
wenn es halt wirklich günstig und Low-Power sein soll.
80 Euro ungefähr bist du mit so einem Board dabei,
das Board hat die CPU schon drauf,
das heißt im Endeffekt,
du brauchst nur noch zwei Sticks RAM
und bist fertig.
Und es braucht ungefähr 7-8 Watt Idle,
inklusive SSD ohne Magnetfestplatten.
Das ist da ganz gut,
da ist auch ein Quad-Core drauf,
also für so kleine Sachen im Heimbereich
reicht das aus.
Wenn du ein bisschen mehr haben willst,
dann musst du dir halt überlegen,
willst du selbst bauen
oder willst du was Fertiges kaufen?
Wenn du was Fertiges kaufen willst,
was auch von der Hardware
und von der Erweiterbarkeit ganz gut ist,
kannst du hier mal gucken,
ob du so einen HP Microserver Plus holen willst,
die Dinger sind ganz gut.
Von denen habe ich jetzt auch seit 2 Jahren
oder so einen im Einsatz.
Leider, und das ist für mich der größte Knackpunkt,
sind die, also das eine ist,
dass die Lüfter-Settings nicht so schön sind,
der ist relativ laut,
wenn er ein bisschen unter Last ist,
was bei mir nicht schlimm ist,
weil der ist ja in einem eigenen Raum hinter mir
und für mich der größte Kritikpunkt,
dass man keine Festplattenwechselrahmen vorne hat,
wo man gut dran kommt.
Aktuell, wenn man die Festplatten wechseln muss,
man hat hier zwar sowas,
aber man muss das dann quasi hinten einmal aufmachen
und rausclipsen für die Platten.
Ansonsten, die Hardware ist okay
und Preis-Leistung ist das Ding auch ganz okay,
wobei du natürlich, wenn du selbst was baust,
preislich besser dabei bist,
auch dir besser was raussuchen kannst,
was du brauchst.
Und eine Sache würde ich mir tatsächlich noch mal überlegen,
ob du alles auf einer Hardware laufen,
auf einer Hardware laufen lassen willst.
Ja, ich weiß, Virtualisierung und so,
ganz nice Geschichte
und ich glaube hier,
er ist auch großer Proxmox-Fan,
zumindest, glaube ich,
bilde ich mir ein,
das aus den Videos mal rausgehört zu haben,
aber man muss sich überlegen,
ob man tatsächlich seine Virtualisierungsplattform
und sein NAS
und sein VPN-Gateway
und solche Geschichten,
ob das wirklich alles unbedingt auf einer Kiste sein soll,
weil, was man im Hinterkopf haben müsste,
ist, was ist denn,
wenn die Kiste mal rebooted werden muss
oder gar,
was ist, wenn die Kiste kaputt geht
und ich hatte,
ich hatte vor Jahren auch mal so eine,
so eine Alleskönner-Kiste,
ich glaube, man sieht die sogar noch
in meinen alten,
in meinen alten Videos,
wo ich mal,
2013?
Hallo Jungs und Mädels,
dem heißt auch,
das ist noch die ganz alte Kiste,
okay,
ja,
also,
ich hatte mal so eine,
dazwischen,
so eine 4HE-Kiste,
man sieht die, glaube ich,
irgendwo auf der,
ich glaube, man sieht die hier am Anfang,
ja, hier sieht man sie noch auf der Erde stehen, ja,
ich hatte so eine,
so eine 4HE-19 Zoll-Kiste,
tatsächlich natürlich mit Noctua-Lüftern und sowas,
die ich zum größten Teil
mir selbst zusammengestellt habe,
weil ich mir gedacht habe,
alter,
wir kaufen nichts Fertiges,
wir kaufen was,
was genau für meine Anforderungen ist,
es war halt komplett oversized für mich daheim,
ja, was gut,
es war halt komplett oversized für mich,
diese Kiste,
aber,
die konnte damals halt schon,
und ich habe das,
das war bestimmt 2017 oder so,
das ist schon eine ganze Weile her,
ohne Probleme 10 Gigabit,
und das auch voll verschlüsselt,
und
durchgängig mit SSD-Cache
und ZFS und allem,
machen,
aber man muss sich halt fragen,
braucht man das daheim,
ja, und ich hatte halt auch den Fehler gemacht,
noch bei der alten Kiste,
bei der,
die man hier gesehen hat noch,
das war ja noch so ein Tower,
da hatte ich ja wirklich alles,
und auch Kabelsalat,
da hatte ich alles auf dieser Kiste damals drauf,
auf diesem Rechner hier neben,
und das war im Nachhinein betrachtet,
gar keine so schlaue Idee,
weil,
ich hatte meinen Router auf der Kiste,
das war damals ein Open Sense,
meine Heimautomatisierung auf der Kiste,
Virtualisierung auf der Kiste,
Nass auf der Kiste,
Filme, Fernsehen, Streaming,
Video gucken auf der Kiste,
ich hatte alles auf der Kiste,
so,
und
ich konnte diese Kiste faktisch nie rebooten,
weil dann immer irgendwas nicht ging,
und es ist auch ganz schön dumm,
die Sachen zu rebooten,
wenn dann dein Internet während dem Reboot nicht geht,
und sowas,
ich habe daraus gelernt,
und habe das jetzt ein bisschen entzerrt,
also sprich,
ich habe jetzt einen eigenen MikroTik Router,
der für mein lokales Routing,
Internetzugang,
PoE für die Access Points,
sorgt,
dann habe ich hier diesen Microserver,
der macht Virtualisierung und Nass,
und Heimautomatisierung läuft da drauf,
und solche,
solche Geschichten.
Ich habe aber auch noch,
einen Raspberry Pi unten im Wohnzimmer stehen,
der zum Beispiel für die Überwachungskameras zuständig ist,
dass das unabhängig von der Kiste oben funktioniert.
Ja, also es macht manchmal schon Sinn,
die Sachen ein bisschen zu,
ein bisschen,
nicht so sehr das zu zentralisieren, ja.
Genau,
das ist das, was ich sagen wollte,
also es macht,
es ist cool, wenn man so eine fette Kiste hat,
die alles machen kann,
aber man muss sich auch mal drüber Gedanken machen,
was ist, wenn die Kiste rebooted wird,
oder mal kurz nicht funktioniert.
Ja,
und das,
und das, was ich eben gezeigt habe,
war halt wahnsinniger Overkill,
diese 4HE-Kiste.
Es tut oftmals sowas kleines,
wie das hier zum Beispiel,
oder aber,
wenn du keine Erweiterbarkeit brauchst,
was PCI Express angeht,
dann tut es auch beispielsweise einen Intel NUC,
wenn du viel CPU-Leistung brauchst,
oder,
irgendwie,
was ich jetzt auch gerade im Chat schon gelesen habe,
irgend so ein Minisforum-PC.
Ich habe hier auch für meine Virtualisierung,
äh nicht Virtualisierung,
für meine Emulator-Kiste so ein Minisforum-PC stehen,
die Dinger sind auch ganz nice.
Also wenn es dir hauptsächlich um Virtualisierung geht,
und du nicht Erweiterbarkeit brauchst,
was PCI Express-Karten angeht,
für 10G-Interfaces und sowas,
dann tut es auch irgendein Mini-PC.
Oder aber, wenn es wirklich günstig sein soll,
kannst du auch so eine Intel Low-Power-Plattform nehmen.
Ich habe es mittlerweile auch nicht,
also das ist ja diese,
wo steht es da hier,
Intel bla bla bla,
das sind die,
das ist eigentlich,
die Dinger heißen zwar mittlerweile,
glaub,
Gemini Lake ist das aktuelle Intel Pentium Gemini Lake,
aber das sind Nachfolger von den Atom-CPUs.
Und mittlerweile gibt es sicherlich was Besseres als dieses Mainboard,
ich habe es nur exemplarisch mal gezeigt,
weil ich sowas hier schon verwendet habe.
Die haben sicherlich auch neuere Varianten davon.
Es gibt Leute,
es gibt Leute,
die daheim einen Kubernetes-Cluster betreiben,
weil es geht.
Kann man alles machen.
Zum Lernen ist das sicherlich auch cool,
ob es einem das Leben so erleichtert,
daheim habe ich meine Zweifel.
Man will ja keinen zweiten Job haben auf der Arbeit.
Zwei Node-Proxmox, kann man alles machen.
Wenn man denkt, dass das notwendig ist für daheim,
kann man das machen.
Ich muss euch sagen,
es gab bei mir nur einen Tag,
wo das komplette Rack ausgefallen ist bei mir.
Und das lag nicht daran,
dass irgendein Service gecrashed ist und nichts mehr ging,
sondern weil die USV den Abgang gemacht hat.
Die USV, die eigentlich dafür da ist,
dafür zu sorgen, dass das Rack weiterläuft.
Seitdem habe ich diese USV auch rausgeschmissen,
weil das bei diesen Cyber-Power-USVs anscheinend ein Feature ist,
dass wenn die Batterie verreckt,
dann das komplette Rack ausgeht,
obwohl die Stromversorgung noch da ist.
Und das ist keine USV,
die alles permanent durch die Batterie leitet,
sondern eine ganz normale
ich-schalte-um-wenn-der-Strom-aus-geht-USV gewesen.
Also warum das so bescheuert gemacht ist,
weiß man nicht.
Aber das ist wohl ein Feature von diesen Cyber-Power-USVs,
was ich sehr beknackt finde.
Und deswegen habe ich die auch nicht mehr.
So, also wir gucken jetzt aber das Heimautomatisierungsvideo fertig.
Also der Kerl...
Ups, nein, nein, nein.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Mist.
Es müssen nun einige Lötverbindungen hergestellt werden.
Ich glaube, hier sind wir tatsächlich stehen geblieben,
auch genau an der Stelle.
So, also der Typ hat ja wirklich total übertrieben.
Nicht nur, dass er selbst alles designt hat,
inklusive Board.
Da muss er erstmal die Skills für haben.
Also der hat bestimmt schon mehr Erfahrung darin,
so was zu bauen.
Hier für die Endlagensensoren,
sowie die elektrischen Anschlüsse des Getriebemotors.
Also bei APC kommt es darauf an,
das kann ich tatsächlich sagen, worauf man gucken muss.
Bei APC kommt es darauf an, was man für eine USV kauft.
Also sprich, das haben die meisten USVs heutzutage.
Dass du irgendeine Schnittstelle hast,
wo du dann mitbekommst,
wenn Batteriestand low ist.
Und entweder ist das ganz einfach gelöst
über einen USB-Anschluss,
oder früher noch ein serielles Kabel,
oder heute halt Serial auf USB,
dass du es direkt an den Rechner melden kannst,
der angeschlossen ist, oder an einen.
Oder aber man stöpselt dort einen Raspberry Pi dran,
oder installiert es bei sich auf dem Server
und hat dann dort irgendein Netzwerk,
verteilt das oder greift den Stand ab
und entscheidet dann, ob man den Server runterfahren muss.
Ja, aber hier wollte ich noch was zu sagen,
war bei APC auch so.
Also diese Geschichte mit,
es geht alles aus, wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Also es gibt zwei Gründe, warum das sein kann.
Das erste ist, das ist eine,
und jetzt alle Leute,
die Physi-Abschlussprüfung gemacht haben,
korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Es ist eine Line Interactive USV.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, ob das stimmt.
Also sprich, es ist eine USV,
wo immer alles durch die Batterie läuft.
Das gibt es auch, hat seine Vorteile,
hat aber auch seine Nachteile,
nämlich zum Beispiel,
was ist, wenn die Batterie verreckt.
Ich glaube, das nannte sich Online-USV.
Line Interactive sind die billigen.
Ich glaube, Online-USV nennt sich das.
Ach, wie auch immer,
Abschlussprüfung ist schon viel zu lange her.
Ja, das ist der eine Fall.
Und der andere Fall ist,
das sind die Billigsten der Billigen,
die aus welchen Gründen auch immer
es nicht abkönnen, wenn die Batterie verreckt,
ohne dass sie Online sind.
Und wie man das zumindest bei RPC
relativ einfach überprüfen kann,
ob die USVs ausgehen,
wenn die Batterie kaputt geht, ist Folgendes.
Ihr müsst gucken, ob die Hotswap-fähig sind.
Alle USVs, die Hotswap-fähig sind,
also wo man die Batterie im laufenden Betrieb tauschen kann,
die gehen auch nicht aus,
wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Und die meisten etwas besseren von RPC
sind Hotswap-fähig.
Das Hotswappen ist bei vielen da ein bisschen abenteuerlich,
so mit Klemmen und Tapes,
wo du die Batterien rausziehen musst und sowas.
Aber es funktioniert.
Wenn ihr eine USV kauft, die Hotswap-fähig ist,
dann könnt ihr auch davon ausgehen,
die geht nicht aus,
wenn die Batterie kaputt geht.
Man kann die vielleicht so einstellen.
Oder man kann in der Software halt einstellen,
der Rechner fährt sich runter,
was ich übrigens auch nur empfehlen kann.
Gerade dadurch, dass man eine USV hat,
bietet es sich ja auch an zu sagen,
wenn das Ding auf 30% runter geht,
dann fahren wir eben die Hardware dran runter.
Das ist ja auch sinnig.
Meistens kommt es gar nicht so weit,
weil solche Ruckler nur sehr kurz sind in Deutschland glücklicherweise.
Aber wenn es mal länger ist,
dann ist es sinnvoll.
Also nach Hotswap-fähigen USVs gucken.
Die müssen auch gar nicht so teuer sein.
Ja und dann wird der Lianer A antrieben.
Also der Typ hat es echt übertrieben.
Der hat nicht nur das komplette 3D-Zeug
in irgendeiner CAD-Anwendung designt,
der hat das Board selbst designt.
Wahrscheinlich hat er jetzt die Firma noch selbst programmiert.
Also da muss ich sagen, Hut ab,
der Kerl hat wirklich Plan.
In das Gehäuse der Ventileinheit eingebaut.
Deswegen heißt es ja auch,
Lüftungsanlagen-Eskalation.
Und fest verschraubt.
Was passiert hier?
Krasser Scheiß.
Das Ventil selber besteht ebenfalls aus
und deren Einzelteilen, die verschraubt werden.
Hier werden zusätzlich die Magnete
für die Endlagenerkennung installiert.
Alter, der hat ja an alles gedacht.
Nun werden noch die Anschlusskabel
zur Hausinstallation angelötet,
sowie die Kabelverbindung zu einem
separaten Temperatur- und Luftfeuchtesensor
und einem Funkinterface angeschlossen.
Was ist denn das?
Ein ESP-286?
Oder was ist das da oben?
Man erkennt es nicht so genau.
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich sowas in der Richtung.
Dann werden alle beweglichen Teile
noch ordentlich eingefettet
und ab geht's zum Erstkontakt der Mechanik.
Ja, läuft.
Zum Schluss wird noch der Sensor
für die Raumtemperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit
auf der Vorderseite installiert.
Alter, guck mal, wie gut das durchdacht ist.
Sogar zum ordentlichen Installieren
hier neben des Controllers.
Also, das sind meine 3D-Drucke
bei weitem nicht auf dem Niveau.
Das Einzige, was ich noch als
...
Verbesserungsvorschlag hätte, wäre ...
Zum Schluss wird noch der Sensor
für die Raumtemperatur ...
Man sieht es ja an der Stelle.
Hier werden Schrauben
in 3D-gedrucktes Plastik geschraubt.
Das Einzige, was ich noch anzumerken hätte,
wären sowas hier.
Sowas hier.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen,
muss ich euch mal ein Video zutaten,
Ja, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Wood, Plastik, Metal, Plastik.
Genau, hier sieht man es ganz gut.
Man nimmt einen Lötkolben.
Irgendwann nimmt er den Lötkolben.
Äh ...
Das ist ein Lötkolben.
Okay, so kann man es auch machen.
Ich kenne das mit Lötkolben, ja.
Ah doch, Lötkolben, okay.
Nimm den Lötkolben und schmilz das rein.
So, guckt.
Yup.
Genau, fertig, zack.
So, und das hat den Vorteil,
dass du halt Schrauben in Metall schrauben kannst
und nicht ins Plastik
vom 3D-gedruckte schrauben musst.
Was wiederum den Vorteil hat,
es leiert nicht aus.
Und diese Dinger, man denkt sich jetzt vielleicht
erst mal so,
wie fest wird das Ganze sein?
Leute, ich kann euch sagen,
das ist bombenfest.
Das ist da mit Hitze reingeschmolzen.
Also du musst es abkühlen lassen,
das ist bombenfest.
Also wenn du die Kraft hättest,
könntest du dich da vielleicht sogar dranhängen.
Das ist bombenfest, das Zeug.
Und generell muss man ja auch sagen,
ist 3D-gedrucktes Material
oder 3D-gedruckte Teile
viel stabiler, als man so
auf den ersten Blick
oder auf den ersten Eindruck denken mag.
Also diese Teile sind sehr stabil.
Und wenn sie nicht stabil genug sind,
ein bisschen mehr Infill rein oder Füllung rein,
die sind stabil.
Also nur mal so,
für was das hält,
ich hab mir ein kleines
Mini-Regal 3D gedruckt.
Also okay, nein, ich hab mir kein
Regal 3D gedruckt, ich hab mir Halterungen
für eine Holzplatte 3D gedruckt.
Hab ich an die Wand geschraubt
und daran,
ich hab irgendwo Bilder,
die find ich jetzt aber auf die Schnelle nicht.
Chat, ihr seid doch immer so feifert.
Habt ihr vielleicht noch irgendwie die Bilder
irgendwo
von meinem Accesspoint, der an der Decke hängt?
Oder an diesem Regal hängt?
Image.cc
oder so was?
Manchmal hat der Chat sowas.
So und,
also ich hab meinen Accesspoint seit
eineinhalb Jahren
an so nem threaded insert
hängen
an der Decke. Der Accesspoint wiegt natürlich
nicht viel. Das Ding wiegt vielleicht
keine Ahnung
ein halbes Kilo oder so. Das ist ja schon ein bisschen
ein bisschen schwerer
ein bisschen
mehr Highend Accesspoint
so ein halbes Kilo oder so vielleicht.
Hängt ja da kopfüber dran.
Allerdings hängt der auch nur an zwei ganz
kleinen Schräubchen mit solchen Inserts dran.
Und
das macht
überhaupt keine
Anstalten, dass das abgeht.
Du kannst da auch deutlich
schwereres hinhängen.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Ne, also das ist ganz praktisch.
In dem Fall ist es
Overkill, weil der Schraub den
Controller hier einmal rein und gut ist.
Sollte man allerdings diese Schraube öfters
mal auf und zu machen müssen, dann wäre
so ein Insert nicht verkehrt,
weil so 3D gedrucktes Material,
das kannst du einmal schrauben.
Das war's. Beim zweiten Mal schrauben hält es schon
nicht mehr richtig.
Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit auf der Vorderseite
installiert. Natürlich.
Ja, und dann wird das System einfach in den
Lüftungsschacht eingeschoben. Und was ich persönlich
schon gemerkt habe, bei 3D gedrucktem
Material sind solche,
zumindest meinem Eindruck nach, sind solche
Schrauben nicht optimal, sondern
eher Schrauben mit etwas
größerem, aber gröberen
Gewinde.
Besser.
Ist zumindest mein Eindruck.
Den kannst du genau einmal
reinschrauben und wahrscheinlich auch dann schon
nicht richtig anziehen.
Und spätestens beim zweiten Mal
schrauben geht das nicht mehr.
Aber trotzdem
mega krasse Konstruktion hier, was er da gebaut
hat. Für alles Selbstdesign.
Es ist ja ein Unterschied, ob man sich
sowas bei Thingiverse raussucht
und einen ESP32
dran klebt und zusammenbaut und gut ist
oder ob man komplett
von dem 3D-Model
bis zur Software auf dem Microcontroller,
bis zur Platine, bis zum
PCP, bis zum Board, bis zum alles selber
designt und alles selber baut.
Das ist schon
nicht ohne.
Natürlich.
Und dann wird das System einfach in den Lüftungsschacht
eingeschoben.
Das System reagiert
nun auf das Signal der zentralen Steuerung.
Und fällt bei laufendem Lüften
das Ventil auf.
Dann wird der Lüfter
abgeschaltet, schließt sich das Ventil
wieder automatisch. Und das sieht auch noch
so aus, als gehört es da hin.
Viele meiner 3D-
gedruckten und vor allem auch meiner Konstruktion
sehen nicht unbedingt so aus,
als gehören sie da auch hin.
Also gerade wie
ich unten die Türklingel
angebunden habe, sieht sehr experimentell aus.
Ja,
durch die integrierte Bluetooth-Schnittstelle kann
die Lüftungseinheit auch mittels einer App
gesteuert werden.
Hier kann also
die Lüftergeschwindigkeit und Richtung,
sowie die Lüftungsdauer eingestellt werden.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein Webinterface.
Das haben wir auch schon gemacht
im Stream.
Webinterface auf dem ESP32 zum
Steuern. Aber Next Level
Shit, Alter.
Zudem wird die aktuelle Raumtemperatur und
Luftfeuchtigkeit in der App angezeigt.
Über den integrierten
Temperatur- und Luftfeuchtesensor kann
das System bei Erreichung eines Grenzwerts
aber auch automatisch lüften. So richtig smart
wird das Ganze aber erst durch die Apple HomeKit
Integration. Ich nutze
hier ein billiges ESP32
Mikrocontroller-Entwicklungsboard mit einigen
Zeilen Code, welches als Bridge
zu den Lüftungseinheiten fungiert.
Die Kommunikation erfolgt auch hier
Five Header Time.
Du hast gerade gesagt,
du hast deine Türklingel angeboten.
Kennst du ein Modul, welches über WLAN geht, das man
sprechen und hören kann? Muss ich gleich
was zu sagen.
Das war tatsächlich echt eine Wissenschaft
für sich, das anzubinden.
Sag ich gleich was zu, wenn wir mit dem Video fertig sind.
Also ja,
ich kann mittlerweile reden,
aber nicht
mit was Selbstgebasteltem, sondern was
vom Hersteller. Allerdings in was Selbstgebasteltes
integriert. Hier per Bluetooth
Low Energy. Wie man sieht, wird
das Entwicklungsboard als Bridge erkannt und in
Homekit eingebunden. Also gleich, wenn das
Performance das nächste ankommt. In diesem Beispiel bringt
die Bridge drei Lüfter.
Das ist schon extrem Pfeilfett, was der Kerl da
gebaut hat. Die zunächst in Räumen
zugewiesen werden müssen.
Was haben wir da gerade gesehen?
Lüftungssteuerung. Hast du irgendwie eine Firma für dezentrale
Lüftungsanlagen gegründet und
hier ein Werbevideo rein gemogelt?
Mal in die Kommentare gucken.
Hier kommt wahrscheinlich, hier kann man das
kaufen.
Das sieht ziemlich cool aus. Es sieht
vor allem professionell aus und so aus, als gehört es
dahin. Und wie du in deiner
Beschreibung der Einsendung angekündigt hast,
ist es vollkommen overengineert.
Ja, das stimmt.
Na, was heißt vollkommen overengineert?
Es ist eigentlich
ordentlich gemacht, so wie es sein
soll, wo die meisten Leute schlicht
ergreifen nicht die Skills. Im Heimbereich
haben sowas selbst zu entwerfen.
Ich
verstehe nicht so richtig, was hier
passiert. Also, du hast gesagt,
dein Vermieter, das ist eine Ferienwohnung.
Bist du da nur
zum Urlaub gewesen und hast mal eben
die Lüftung umgebaut?
Nicer Urlaub.
Kommt die Frau zu ihm so nach dem Motto,
ey Schatz, lass doch mal ein bisschen am Strand
spazieren gehen. Moment, Moment.
Die Firma für die Lüftungssteuerung muss fertig
werden. So, 14 Tage Urlaub rum.
Wir fahren jetzt heim. Endlich funktioniert
die Lüftungssteuerung. Aber ist doch
ein entspannter Urlaub.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ich habe obendrauf ein bisschen
das Problem, dass das, was ich gerade
gesehen habe, macht, dass ich mich völlig inadäquat
fühle.
Jetzt mal was
zu meiner
Türklingel.
Meine
Türklingel, das ist
eine Story von
1-2 Jahren gewesen, bis ich da was wirklich
Sinnvolles gebaut habe. Und mittlerweile,
muss ich sagen, habe ich auch vieles wieder abgebaut,
weil man es eigentlich gar nicht gebraucht hat.
So, also das fing bei mir
alles an, dass ich eine Türklingel
habe. Bei mir, das ist so eine Siedle
Anlage,
Gegensprechanlage.
Sowas in der Richtung ist das.
Nur was richtig Altes
noch. Sieht ein bisschen aus
wie das hier. Also die ist
nicht smart, meine Tür
Gegensprechanlage. Es gibt so ein paar
Telefone und so. Das ist alles analog
über Kabel
im Haus.
Und was mir jetzt vorgeschwebt ist,
waren, also
warum ich mich überhaupt mit Automatisierung
damit beschäftigt hatte, war,
ich wollte, dass
ich auf dem
Telefon
Gespräche
von der Tür Gegensprechanlage annehmen
kann. Und mit Telefon meine ich sowohl bei
mir per VoIP auf dem Handy,
als auch auf dem Decktelefon,
wenn man mal auf dem Balkon ist oder sowas.
Oder nicht auf dem Balkon, auf der Terrasse ist.
Kein Balkon, auf der Terrasse
ist. Weil da hat man oftmals das Handy
dabei oder das Telefon dabei und will halt mitbekommen,
wenn es klingelt. Beziehungsweise auch
mit den Reden. So, das war so der Stein
des Anschlusses. Dann habe ich geguckt, wie kann man das
Ganze machen.
Ich habe nichts Gescheites gefunden,
gut zu integrieren
und dann habe ich angefangen, selbst zu bauen.
Als erstes habe ich in das
Telefon
einen ESP32
eingebaut. Das haben wir sogar hier im Stream
entworfen, das Ding. Mit einem
Magnet, der erkennt, wenn das
Telefon aufgelegt ist
und der erkennt mit einem
Analog-Digital-Konverter,
ob geklingelt
wird. Da haben wir so eine Mini-Schaltung
nachgebaut. Haben wir auch im Stream
zusammengebaut. Das ist schon ein bisschen her.
Dass man erkennt, wenn es klingelt.
Das war aber alles
irgendwie ein bisschen doof.
Hat mir alles nicht gefallen. Hat auch alles
nicht so gut funktioniert. Und dann habe ich
irgendwann bei Ebay
mir ein
analoges Telefon-Modul
gekauft, günstig, für meine
Türsprechanlage. Das hat irgendein Typ
ausgebaut und auf Ebay verkauft. Das habe
ich dann irgendwie für, keine Ahnung,
70 Euro oder so da gekauft. Neu
kostet das irgendwie, ganz ehrlich
Leute, diese Gegensprech-
anlagentechnologie ist echt schwarze Magie.
Also das ist auch so gemacht,
dass da niemand durchblickt. Und ich habe tatsächlich auch
Herstellerhandbücher gelesen dazu,
dass ich halbwegs verstehe, wie das
funktioniert. Ich habe mir dann bei Ebay
so ein Modul gekauft, wo man
ein analoges Telefon anschließen konnte
dafür. Und das habe ich dann
mit der Fritzbox verbunden
und so ist das Ganze
dann über VoIP gegangen.
Leider hat so natürlich
meine Heimautomatisierung immer noch nicht mitbekommen,
wenn es geklingelt hat.
So, und dafür habe ich
im Keller einen Raspberry Pi stehen,
der macht noch ein paar mehr Sachen,
aber der hat unter anderem einen
so ein Teil dran.
Ja, so, sowas.
Hat der Raspberry Pi
dran.
Da kannst du, also das ist nicht
das Einzige, was der macht, aber es bietet
sich an, es dafür mitzubenutzen.
Das ist ein Board, da hast du mehrere
Funktionen drauf. Ich habe übrigens noch eins ohne Display.
Da hast du mehrere Funktionen drauf.
Du hast einmal einen Relay, um was zu schalten, an der
Stelle hier. Du hast allerdings
auch drei
Analog-Digital-
Konverter, die bis,
glaub, 48 Volt gehen.
Ja, und wenn man Türöffner bedienen will, kann man das auch...
Ah ne, 24 Volt. Blödsinn, nicht 48, 24 Volt.
Was genau passt
für mich, weil meine Türsprechanlage
funktioniert folgendermaßen. Das ist
wirklich, wie gesagt, das ist komplett schwarze Magie.
Das funktioniert alles über
zwei Drähte. Also das ist nicht so, dass
jedes Telefon ein eigenes dreht, aber zwei Drähte.
Und das Ding hat
Ruhespannung, 22 Volt.
Wenn es klingelt, 18 Volt.
Und wenn telefoniert wird,
20 Volt. Also das
moduliert das alles. So, und die
Sprachsignale werden auch moduliert auf diese
Leitung drauf. Das macht das alles über die Spannung,
die anliegt, dass die Telefone
erkennen, was sie machen müssen. Das ist wirklich
Oldschool-Analoge-
Pfeifertechnik, wo sonst keiner durchblickt,
außer der Hersteller. Und
ich hab das hier
dran angeschlossen, und ich hab jetzt
im Hintergrund laufen, wenn halt
die Spannung droppt auf 18
Volt, oder 15,
ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was es ist, dann bedeutet
das, es hat geklingelt.
Und so bekomme ich das
in meine Heimautomatisierung.
Und über dieses Siedle-Analog-Telefon-
Anschluss-Ding bekomme ich es bei mir in die Fritzbox.
So, das hat auch ganz gut
funktioniert. Eine Kamera ist natürlich
nicht dabei. Ich hab da noch, und das haben wir
auch zusammen im Stream programmiert,
ich hab da noch was programmiert,
was auch auf dem Raspberry Pi läuft,
was die Kamera
von mir am Hoftor
multiplext mit
dem VoIP-Call
dieses Siedle-Analog-Dings. Also das
macht quasi ein Zip-Call draus,
als Audio-Source
den Call von dem Siedle-Ding
und als Video-Source
die Kamera bei mir
am Hoftor
und macht daraus einen neuen
Zip-Call mit Video drinnen.
So hab ich dann zum Beispiel am Handy,
wenn ich am Handy drangehe,
kann ich am Handy das Video sehen
von der Kamera am Hoftor,
plus theoretisch
den Sound von der Gegensprechanlage,
was im Keller abgegriffen wird.
So, das hatte ich eine Weile laufen,
das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert,
wenn es auch ein bisschen behelfsmäßig zusammengebaut war,
das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert und irgendwann
ist mir aufgefallen, Max,
das ist maßlos over-ingeniert.
Du hast das jetzt zwei Jahre oder so
benutzt und du hast nicht einmal
mit jemand gesprochen an der Tür
und du hast dir auch
eine Handvoll Mal nur das Video
angeguckt in dem Call.
Deswegen hab ich das jetzt vereinfacht.
Deswegen hab ich dieses Siedler-Ding
wieder abgebaut.
Dieses Teil, was ich mir auf Ebay gekauft hab,
gibt kein VoIP-Call mehr
und das Einzige, was ich jetzt mache, ist,
ich
hab noch den Raspberry Pi dran,
ich detekte, wenn es klingelt
und wenn es klingelt,
gibt es über eine Automatisierung
im Home Assistant
eine Push-Notification
ans Handy.
Mit
einem Bild von der Kamera.
Das ist alles. Das reicht in der Regel auch.
Weil reden mit dem Typ
will ich eh nicht und mir reicht schon,
wenn ich sehe, ach gut, das ist der DHL-Typ gewesen.
Fertig. Reicht.
Und ich hab noch was
mit verbunden.
Ich hab noch was damit verbunden.
Da hängt noch ein kleines Skript dran,
was das Telefon
klingeln lässt.
Was dann quasi einen VoIP-Call
an die Fritzbox abschickt,
was das Telefon klingeln lässt.
Aber du kannst nicht mehr
Rücksprache halten mit den Leuten.
Ich hab's wieder
deutlich vereinfacht,
als das, was ich ursprünglich gebaut hab.
Weil ich festgestellt hab, ich brauch das meiste gar nicht.
Ja, das war wirklich,
wir haben auch einiges im Stream gemacht,
da zusammen. Ich glaube, wenn man hier mal ins Archiv guckt,
Tür.
Türklingel, Audio plus Kamera plus
Telefon.
Hier haben wir irgendwas gebastelt, haben wir irgendwas
geübt mit VoIP.
Tür gegen Sprechanlage.
Es gab auch Bastel-Streams dazu,
wo man den Kram zusammengelötet hat.
Ja, hier. Hier haben wir auch den Kram teilweise
zusammengelötet dabei.
Das ist tatsächlich hier der,
das ist wirklich das Teil, was wir da gebaut haben.
Das ist das, was ich dann am,
das ist das, was ich dann
bei mir in die Telefone
von der Tür gegen Sprechanlage testweise
mal eingebaut habe, was erkannt hat,
wenn's klingelt und ob,
also da war so ein kleiner
Magnetsensor drin,
der hat erkannt, wann's Telefon aufgelegt ist
und per Analog-Digital-Converter
erkannt, ob es klingelt.
Der musste halt klein sein, das ist so
ein Tiny Pico ESP32.
Die Dinger sind ungefähr so groß wie ein Daumennagel.
Man sieht ja auch hier ganz schön
rangesumt.
Ungefähr so groß wie ein Daumennagel.
Aber das hab ich auch
alles nicht mehr.
Dafür weiß ich jetzt, wie das interne
Protokoll meiner Tür gegen Sprechanlage
funktioniert, dass es klingelt.
Und wenn ihr nur mitbekommen wollt,
es gibt übrigens einen Tipp, den ich euch da
an der Stelle geben kann, wenn ihr nur mitbekommen
wollt, ob eure
Klingel, ob es geklingelt hat,
also mal angenommen, ihr wollt nur mitbekommen,
ihr wollt euch eine Push-Notification
schicken, oder sag mal so,
euer Heimautomatisierung-System
soll mitbekommen, wenn es klingelt.
Was ihr dann damit macht, ist was anderes.
Also die einfachste Sache, was ich euch
empfehlen kann, ist,
wenn ihr diese Geräte nicht öffnen wollt
und wenn ihr alles im
Werkszustand lassen wollt,
was vielleicht auch sinnvoll ist,
wenn ihr
zur Miete wohnt, ihr könnt
immer noch hier einen Controller
dran machen mit so einem
Mikrofon-Lautstärke-Sensor, weil
die Klingel ist laut und wenn das anschlägt,
dann schickt ihr einfach, macht ihr einen
Get-Request auf eure
Home-Automation-Plattform und setzt da halt
einen Flag, dass es geklingelt hat.
Ja.
Das hast du schon.
Ja, aber Tür-Gegensprechanlage
war wirklich eine
Wissenschaft
für sich.
Das war ziemlich Pfeifett, was man
dafür alles machen musste. Und am Ende
hab ich's jetzt ja noch nicht mal wirklich benutzt
und hab's wieder abgebaut.
Aber ich wollte es einfach
ich weiß nicht,
ich geb bei sowas immer
nicht auf. Wenn ich angefangen hab, sowas zu
bauen, dann wird das meistens auch gebaut,
bis es funktioniert und irgendwann, wenn's dann
funktioniert, stell ich fest, eigentlich ist
das total overkill und ich hätt's gar nicht gebraucht.
So, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Shortcut. Heute noch ein
Shortcut an Bord und zwar hat Michael
Oh ne, das interessiert mich nicht. Irgendwelche Leute,
die Apple-Shortcut-Dinger.
Das ist auch oftmals
maßlos overengineert.
Mit irgendwelchen
CSVs, das ist zu abgedreht.
Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Klopapier-Automation.
Benutzt du
den Switchboard?
Ne, tatsächlich hab ich den Switch. Ich hab zwei
Switchboards hier und Switchboards sind auch eine super Erfindung
für Sachen, die sich nicht anderweitig
automatisieren lassen, aber aktuell
hab ich keinen der beiden Switchboards im Einsatz.
Da hab ich nichts mehr, wofür
ich das brauch.
Ich hatte das mal unten in der Küche, bei einem Schalter,
hatte ich das mal.
Überleg gerade.
Ups, glaub das war's.
Okay, Klopapier-Automation.
Bin mal gespannt.
Dann hab ich von Leon noch was bekommen. Es geht um
ein Gästebadezimmer
im Keller.
Klopapier leer.
Ah, das ist, da kann man draufdrücken, wenn
das Klopapier leer ist. Eigentlich
eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Okay.
Das ist also, was wir jetzt machen.
Eingehende Übertragung, der Inhalt ist,
Haushalt wurde benachrichtigt,
Hilfe sollte in Kürze eintreffen.
Der Suchtrupp kommt.
Eingehende Übertragung, der Inhalt ist,
jemand hat den Klopapier
leer, Knopf gedrückt im Kellerbad,
bitte welches vorbeibringen.
Okay, ja, also ich wünschte,
ich könnte es als völlig bescheuert abtun.
Aber eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Wenn das öfters
vorkommt.
Eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Ich finde es eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Ich mein, ich hab das Problem,
nicht?
Genauso mach ich das.
Bei mir liegt einfach
das Klopapier, ein Stapel im
Klo. Also ich
hab so einen alten Wäschekorb,
der ist halt kein Wäschekorb mehr,
sondern der ist voll mit Klopapier.
Und den hab ich auch immer vorm Klo stehen,
weil da kann ich mein iPad drauf
ablegen. Also wenn ich
auf dem Klo sitze und das Klopapier ist
all, dann mach ich das iPad vom Wäschekorb
runter, mach den Wäschekorb
auf, hol ein neues Klopapier
raus und dann ist gut.
Ja, manche
Leute haben das ja in irgendeinem Vorratsschrank
und sowas.
Du nutzt ein... wieso kann
jeder machen, was er will.
Ich benutze ja auch
zum größten Teil
nur zum Abtrocknen
das Klopapier.
Ich hab auch einen...
Also ich hab kein extra Bidet, ich hab einen Klo
mit so einer Spülfunktion für ein Pobbes.
Passt mal auf, ich hab sogar ein Video
zu
Klo-FPS.
Oder, ich hab sogar
noch ein aktuelleres Video.
Das ist das alte 8 Jahre
Premium-Klo-Fazit.
Genau, das brauchen wir, da ist er.
An's Trinken erinnern, Dankeschön.
Das ist übrigens der Wäschekorb, den ihr hier seht.
Das ist der eben
angesprochene Wäschekorb.
Der ist voller
Klopapier und normalerweise benutze ich
den als iPad-Ablage und der
steht da vor.
Die Waage
ist übrigens POG.
Der trägt mein Gewicht per Bluetooth.
Ihr seht's
vielleicht hier neben. Hier neben gibt es eine Steckdose.
Die kannst du per
Home-Automation an- und ausschalten.
Die hat allerdings auch zwei USB-Anschlüsse.
Die du auch
remote ein- und ausschalten kannst.
Hier seht ihr ein USB-Kabel und ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich es im Video zeige.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich zeig's nicht im Video.
Hier hinten
an dem USB-Kabel
hängt gut versteckt
ein ESP32
dran.
Der macht Bluetooth-Empfang
für die Waage, für ein paar
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren
und für einen
Temperatursensor
im Kühlschrank.
Die funken alle per Bluetooth-Low Energy
und der ESP32
haben wir übrigens auch im Stream
angefangen zu programmieren.
Das kann ich fast zu jedem Thema sagen.
Haben wir übrigens auch im Stream gemacht.
Die Firmware darauf haben wir auch
angefangen im Stream zu programmieren.
Der lauscht per Bluetooth
ob es Meldungen gibt
und schickt die dann über WLAN
per MQTT weiter an die
Heimautomatisierung.
Taylor, das
kaufe ich mir nicht. Ich glaube, was du verlinkt hast
ist dieses Urin-Analyse-Ding.
Das finde ich komplett unsinnig.
Das hat auch nur mit der Hersteller-Cloud richtig funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja auch so ein Klo mit
Spülung drin. Man sieht es hier irgendwo.
Hast du was mit dem Raspberry Pi
Pico gemacht? Nee.
Ich habe mir mal so ein Zweierpack
gekauft, als die neu waren. Einfach just for fun.
Und habe festgestellt, ach Mist, die haben ja
gar kein WLAN. Mittlerweile gibt es
die auch mit WLAN, wobei ich bei mir
zum Schluss gekommen bin,
warum sollte ich den verwenden, wenn ich auch einfach
den ESP32 verwenden kann.
Der ESP32 hat mehrere Kerne, ist schneller.
Ja gut, er hat nicht
Raspberry Pi draufstehen.
So, ich labere jetzt hier noch ein bisschen.
Ach guck mal, hier zeige ich es doch.
Hier sieht man es. Hier ist der ESP32 drin.
In einer wasserdichten
Box.
Und der hängt
normalerweise an der Wand,
Klodeckel.
Warum
wasserdichte Box? Naja, ich dusche ja da auch
drinnen und Luftfeuchtigkeit und sowas.
Alles klar.
Genau, das ist die Fernbedienung vom Klo.
Da kann man
ganz viele Sachen einstellen.
Wasserstopp, Start,
Wasserdruck,
Föhn.
Also das Klo hat
einen Föhn, da kann man sich den Poppers
abföhnen lassen, wenn der nass ist.
Man kann die Position verändern.
Damenspülung,
verschiedene Presets,
Abzug von
unangenehmen Gerüchen,
die Art wie es ist, eine Heizung
vom Wasser, also alle möglichen Shit kann man da einstellen.
Und zumindest
am Ende sieht das Ganze so aus.
Wenn man auf den Knopf drückt, dann
Ja, Max, drück mal
auf den Knopf. Ich muss das
übrigens so hinhalten, weil das hat eine Lichtschranke.
Wenn keiner drauf sitzt,
dann geht das ja auch mit dem Wasser nicht.
Dann drückt man drauf
und irgendwann
irgendwann fährt dann das Ding aus
und
sprayt dir Wasser
in den
Poppers rein.
Und dann gibt es noch
einen Föhn, der auch rausgefahren kommt
und einem hintern abbläst.
Den Föhn benutze ich allerdings
nicht. Ich trockne das am liebsten mit
Klopapier ab.
Ich mag das nicht, Poppers geföhnt zu kriegen.
Ja.
Da muss man aber richtig sitzen.
Klappt
ganz gut. Da trifft eigentlich immer die Stelle.
Ja.
Wenn du falsch sitzt,
dann
wird es
ein Föhn.
Und dann
ist es
auch ein Föhn.
Und dann
ist es
ein Föhn.
Und dann
ist es
ein
Föhn.
Und dann
ist es
ein
Föhn.
Und dann
ist es
ein
Föhn.
Und dann
ist es
ein
Föhn.
Und dann
ist es
ein
Föhn.
Ja.
Und das
zweite ist, was sich auch gelohnt
hat, den
gescheiten Stuhl hier anzuschaffen.
Gescheiten Stuhl
für den Schreibtisch.
Den habe ich jetzt
auch schon knapp, ja,
denke mal so
acht, neun Jahre
vielleicht, acht Jahre, oder so den Stuhl.
der lohnt sich wirklich für mich. Es hat sich gelohnt, da die Kohle auszugeben. Ich sitze so
viel hier vorm Rechner, nicht nur Homeoffice-technisch, auch außerhalb, dass einfach ein
guter Stuhl echt das Wichtigste ist. Das sollte man nicht sparen, gerade was Rücken angeht und
Rückenschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen, alles ein guter Stuhl ist sehr wichtig. Ja, so viel dazu.
Welchen Stuhl hast du? Das Ding heißt, ist von Sedus, ich glaube Mr.24 heißt das Ding.
Ah, habe ich doch sogar schon mal danach gesucht. Sedus Mr.24 heißt das Ding.
Gut zu wissen, Chainlore, so schaut das Ding aus. Ja gut, die Webseite ist ziemlicher Crap,
aber so sieht das Ding aus. Jetzt gibt es verschiedene, verschiedene. Also ich habe
dieses Ding als Kopfstütze. Ja, kann man sich aussuchen. Das Coole ist halt daran,
du kannst so gut wie alles einstellen an dem Stuhl. Den Abstand zwischen Lehne und Sitz,
die Armlehnen sind dreidimensional verstellbar, hoch, runter, vorne, hinten, links, rechts,
sogar schräg kannst du die teilweise dadurch machen. Du kannst einstellen, dass es nicht
umklappt, dass es nur bis zur Hälfte umklappt, wie hart es Widerstand hat beim Zurückklappen,
Höhen verstellbar. Also das hat wirklich alles und der Stuhl ist zugelassen bis 250 Kilo.
Ich meine, ich brauche es nicht. Mittlerweile, ich habe ein bisschen abgenommen, ich bin jetzt
bei 91 Kilo, aber wenn man sich da drauf schmeißt auf den Stuhl, ja, also ich hüpfe ja immer so
halt auf den Stuhl drauf. Ich setze mich ja nicht ordentlich hin, also wenn ich mich hinsetze,
stelle ich mich immer vor den Stuhl und mache so, zack, setze mich da drauf. Da auch 90 Kilo oder
91 Kilo mal so kurz beim Auftreffen wiegt halt ein bisschen was und deswegen ist gut, dass der
sehr stabil ist und auch schön aus Metall und allem und bis zu 250 Kilo zugelassen. Da muss
ich mir keine Gedanken machen, dass da irgendwas kaputt geht. Wie heißt der? Sedus Mr.24. Was
der kostet? Ja, das ist tatsächlich der größte Negativpunkt wahrscheinlich an dem Stuhl.
Intro-Idee mit dem Stuhl reinhüpfen. Ja, weil er fett. Der ist halt ein bisschen teurer. Klingt
jetzt erstmal abgedreht, warum sollte man sich einen Stuhl für 1.500 bis 2.000 Euro kaufen,
aber ehrlich Leute, wenn ihr den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzt im Homeoffice, für YouTube und
Twitch vorm Rechner sitzt und auch so für Technik und sonstige Sachen vorm Rechner sitzt, wenn ihr
so viel vorm Rechner sitzt wie ich, ist ein guter Stuhl eine gute Investition, auch wenn er ein
bisschen teurer ist. Gibt sicherlich auch andere gute Stühle, die nicht so teuer sind. Also ich
habe den... Der ausschlaggebende Punkt, warum ich ihn gekauft habe, war damals, weil ich bei
irgendeinem Online-Store das im Angebot gesehen habe für glaube ich 1.200 Euro oder sowas und ich
dachte, ey, das ist so viel günstiger als normalerweise, dann kaufst du dir den jetzt.
Das ist tatsächlich der größte Negativpunkt an dem Stuhl, ist halt echt teuer. Aber trotzdem,
im Ernst, ich sitze so viel davor, dass ich die Investition auch da irgendwie jetzt nicht
wirklich gerechnet habe, aber auch gelohnt habe. Ich habe keine Rückenprobleme mehr. Gut,
dass ich keine Rückenschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen und sowas mehr habe, liegt wahrscheinlich auch
daran, weil ich mich am Tag jetzt mindestens eineinhalb, zwei Stunden sportlich betätige
und das jeden Tag, mit Einschränkung manchmal vielleicht sonntags weniger. Das dürfte
wahrscheinlich den... Also mehr Sport plus abgenommen, das in Kombination hat sicherlich
auch dazu geführt, dass ich weniger Kopfschmerzen, Rückenprobleme habe, also gar keine mehr. Also
ich muss ja wirklich sagen, ich bin jetzt mit 38, fast 39 so fit, wie ich seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr
gewesen bin. Doch, die Rückenlehne kannst du auch einstellen. Gehst du jeden Tag eine
Stunde? Ja. Wobei spazieren, ich laufe schon schneller als spazieren. Eineinhalb Stunden
jeden Tag, eher mittlerweile... Ja doch, eineinhalb Stunden. Ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben.
Es gibt durchaus Tage, da laufe ich auch mehr, da sind es sogar über zwei. Also aufgesplit...
Es sind auf jeden Fall jeden Tag über zwei Stunden, allerdings nicht am Stück. Aber
es gibt Tage, da laufe ich auch eineinhalb und eher zwei Stunden am Stück. Gerade jetzt
am Samstag, wenn man ein bisschen größere Runde machen kann. Also gestern zum Beispiel
war ich so 1,45 Uhr vormittags hier ein bisschen im Gebirge. Ich nenne es Gebirge, die Schweizer
sagen es ist kein Gebirge. Aber hier bei uns im Spessart ein bisschen unterwegs, so Stunde
45, zwei Stunden in dem Dreh. Und dann bin ich nachmittags noch mal einkaufen gelaufen,
so ein bisschen über eine Stunde. Also komme ich auf ungefähr zweieinhalb Stunden,
zwei Stunden 45 oder so Bewegung am Tag und das jeden Tag. Und seitdem habe ich keinerlei
Rückenprobleme mehr und ich habe abgenommen. An Tagen, wo ich frei habe morgens und abends
beziehungsweise nachmittags noch mal eine Runde, wenn es sich anbietet.
Schrittzähler. Ja, es gibt irgendwelche Fitnesstracker, habe ich aber nicht. Ich jogge
nicht. Ich habe so Nordic Walking Stöcke und laufe damit rum, so richtig Rentner Boomer
mäßig. Aber auch relativ zackig, sodass man schon ein bisschen ins Schwitzen kommt. Aber
es macht auch keinen Sinn, sich komplett zu verausgaben, dass man da fertig ist. Am
besten Fett verbrennen tut man ja bei, frag mich nicht, ich kenne mich damit nicht aus,
aber ich glaube am besten Fett verbrennen ist ja eh so im mittleren Leistungs, im mittleren
Spektrum, dass man es auch eine Weile durchhält. Fahrrad zur Arbeit kann ich leider nicht
gescheit fahren. Ich hoffe ja, dass sie es irgendwann mal schaffen. Den nördlichen und
südlichen Main Fahrrad Schnellweg zu bauen. Allerdings so langsam, wie solche Bauvorhaben
sind. Es gibt ja hier Fahrrad Schnellweg Hanau. Ja, die wollen ja mehrere Wege bauen von Hanau
nach Frankfurt. Ja, nördlich des Mains und südlich des Mains. Ich würde dann, wenn schon,
den hier fahren. Aber die kriegen es halt nicht gebacken. Es gibt da regelmäßig News dazu und das
letzte, was ich dazu gehört habe, ist, dass eine Umsetzungsstudie in Auftrag gegeben wurde. Also
wenn ich sowas schon höre, dann weißt du Bescheid, es dauert noch mal vorneweg 15 Jahre,
bis so ein Fahrradweg da ist. Lass doch mal News gucken, was gibt's denn da? Warum der Rad
Schnellweg von Frankfurt nach Hanau nicht vorankommt? Tja, weil man wieder unfähig ist,
sowas einfaches wie einen Fahrradweg zu bauen. Ich gebe zu, es gibt sicherlich Hindernisse und
Hürden dazu, aber man sollte, weil die Chinesen hätten da kein Problem mit. Die würden einfach
über alles drüber walzen und hätten einen Radweg gebaut. Wurden halt ein paar Arbeiter mit ein
zementiert auf dem Weg, aber das interessiert die nicht. Dafür haben sie einen Fahrradweg am Start.
Letzter Monat gibt es nichts dazu. Also da tut sie nichts. Wahrscheinlich brauchen die
zehn Jahre dafür, bis dieser Fahrradweg da ist. Wenn du es eigentlich googeln,
Bart. Ich habe es noch nie benutzt. Das, was ich bisher von gehört habe, soll das Ding ja für
normale Sachen eher ein bisschen schlechter als Chat-GPT sein. Dafür soll Bart relativ viel so
esoterischen Kram von sich geben. Ja, deswegen versuche ich mich auch am Tag mindestens eineinhalb
Stunden zu bewegen. Auch jeden Tag, auch jeden Arbeitstag immer. Ein einziger Tag vielleicht,
wo es ein bisschen weniger ist. Vielleicht sonntags, aber ansonsten jeden Tag durchgängig. Und es hat
gebracht. Ich meine, durch wenige Essen habe ich nicht abgenommen. Ich habe einfach durch mehr
Bewegen abgenommen. Ich fresse immer noch Mengen. Vielleicht minimal gesünder als früher,
aber Mengen immer noch. Massen. Hast du schon mal Open Assistant ausprobiert? Nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay, Leute. Es ist zwölf vor dreißig. Was gibt es heute zu essen bei euch? Und ratet
mal. Was meint ihr, was es bei mir zu essen gibt? Ich weiß, dass es manche gibt, die das wissen.
Okay, bei euch gibt es Frühlingsrollen. Bei mir gibt es Nudeln, richtig. Nudeln mit? Was
gibt es bei mir? Nudeln mit? Nudeln mit Lachs, korrekt. So wie gefühlt jeden Sonntag.
Gestern Steak, ihr kauft heute Gasflasche. FeelsBadMan. Hast du nicht noch so Oldschool
mit Kohle? Das habe ich nicht gehört, vom Bing-Chatbot, der User bedroht. Allerdings
hat Microsoft und Bing, was so AI angeht, ja so eine gewisse Geschichte. Vielleicht erinnert
sich noch einer an den Nazi-Bot von Microsoft damals. Die hatten einen Twitter-Bot und gut,
man muss sagen, ich glaube damals hat 4chan auch versucht, ihn ein bisschen zu trollen und hat den
Bot trainiert mit merkwürdigen Dingen. Nee, nicht Elisa, der hieß T oder sowas. Thea oder so hieß
der, glaube ich. Thea? Thea hieß das Ding, genau, den meine ich hier. Thea-Bot. Ja. Oh,
der hat dann irgendwann irgendwelche Nazi-Sprüche gepostet, aber er war schon 2016. Und dann hat
Microsoft den wieder, genau, er verursachte nachfolgend eine öffentliche Kontroverse,
als der Bot damit begann, die Microsoft-Chain den Dienst nach nur 16 Stunden wieder abzuschalten.
Guck, solche Dinge hat der Bot gepostet. Und solche Dinge hat der Bot damals gepostet,
ja. Das ging halt ziemlich nach hinten los, das Experiment von Microsoft. Und dann mussten
sie das Ding wieder abschalten. Nach nur 16 Stunden. Also, dass Microsoft AI komische
Dinge schreibt, da hat man ja schon, haben sie Erfahrung mit. Ja, und dass Bing gerade diese
Bing-Chat-GPT-Geschichte am Anfang blöde Sachen geschrieben hat, das ist ja bekannt. Super! Jetzt
hast du meinem Fake-Account was gegiftet. Nice, dankeschön. Pog. Äh, nicht meinem Fake-Account,
meinem Platzhalter-Account was gegiftet. Sehr schön. Danke für den gegifteten Sub hier. Pogu.
Ja, schön gedodget, Chainlor. Ich habe mir den Account hier absichtlich reserviert,
weil, also den Account habe ich mir schon lange reserviert, bevor es Wobblers überhaupt gab auf
Twitch. Aber ich habe mich ja dann zuentschieden, ich mache es mit dem Account hier, fange an zu
streamen. Aber für den Fall der Fälle, dass ich Wobblers doch mal in Max-FPS umbenennen will,
habe ich den Account. Dienstag Vorstellungsgespräch, du bist gehypt. Warum bist du gehypt?
Ich will das aber wissen. Danke für den weiteren Giftsub. Aufregende neue Arbeitsstelle. Als was,
wenn ich fragen darf, als was hast du dich beworben, falls du das im Chat sagen willst? Ich
glaube du hast sogar schon mal im Chat gesagt und ich habe es vergessen. Poki-Virgin-Check.
Internetentwickler, ne hast du nicht. Pogu, ja dann drücke ich dir die Daumen,
dass das funktioniert. Kannst ja berichten mal nächste Woche, wie es lief. Okay, Chainlor,
Rat bestanden. So Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Wir sehen uns. Eventuell,
jetzt übertreib's ja mal nicht. Nur die Besten der Besten, die hier gegiftet werden.
Hättest du uns mal lieber ein Onlyfans Gift gegiftet?
Also macht's gut, bis dann.
Wir sehen uns.